hey man it's me kevin smith look at me
my funny goofy hat don't i look like
hella from thor don't you sometimes just
want to club that kevin smith well how
about instead you joined that kevin
smith club oh my god we've been having
such a good time we have hours of audio
kids in the smodcast podcast archives
that you can stick into your ear holes
and listen to or do you want to look at
something are you one of them dirty
[ __ ] well then go to the smithstoneian
screening room where you can watch
hundreds of hours of video of my entire
career spanning from the beginning up
till now including my daily morning show
wake and bake man will we just smoke
weed hang out and i tell you what i'm
working on plus there's exclusive events
we've had clerks three screenings for
our club members we've had smod castle
exclusive shows for our members back in
jersey we do events all the time
including movies pop-ups and there's
tons of merchandise of course that that
kevin smith club members get exclusive
access to before anybody else there are
so many ways into that kevin smith club
ladies and gentlemen you don't have to
come through the front door you can come
through the back door we like it that
way sign up as a clerk where you get
access to all the audio that we got or
join as a mall rep that gives you all
the audio and all the video as well or
join as a fun employee ladies and
gentlemen you'll get a new t-shirt an
exclusive that kevin smith club t-shirt
every quarter or join as a yoga hoser
and get yourself something cool like
that kevin smith waking bake bowl ladies
and gentlemen those are our existing
levels but what about the new levels
that's right for 2022 we've added some
levels including the fashionable mail
you get everything that the clerk the
mall rat the yoga hoser and the fun
employee gets but you also get once a
year an exclusive piece of wardrobe from
a kevin smith film straight out the
viewers universe from the secret stash
archives or join as a brand new ranger
danger man that gives you everything
that the clerk the mall rep the fun
employee and the yoga hoser gets as well
as what the fashionable male gets but
then you also once a year get an
exclusive prop direct from one of my
movies and if you've got untold riches
coming out of your ass guess what holy
cow there's the golden calves level man
for that level you come to my house i
cook you dinner we record a podcast and
we shoot it for wake and bake and it
goes up on smodcast man very exclusive
once a year we do that join us at
thatkevinsmithclub.com be a clerk be a
mall rep be a fun employee be a yogos or
be a fashionable male be a ranger danger
or be a golden calf ladies and gentlemen
i'll be waking and baking for you come
join me at that kevin smith club
[Music]
tape
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
hey
hello
[ __ ] man we're doing it me and mark
bernardin [ __ ] doing our show welcome
batman i'm kevin smith i am mark bernard
hey
i love when we do home shows because we
can play with the frame when we're in
the bar you know we're kind of left to
the devices of being live in a room or
whatnot and then the camera is very far
away from us but here when we do home
shows we could do [ __ ] like this
this is what it looks like if i'm eating
you out mark
oh man and you look up at me and i make
perfect eye contact
[Laughter]
um mark's not gonna be able to
concentrate on the show now because he's
just like i've never thought of that
before and now all i can think is these
forms
[Laughter]
oh listen to [ __ ] mark bernard is
going to name drop a bunch of [ __ ]
famous people that he got to hang out
with last night i was i was at a movie
premiere
um which i don't get to go to as much as
i used to back when i was a working
journalist it was a thing
but uh but it's become few and far
between but like last night i got this
invite to go to see this movie and i was
like well [ __ ] it i'm going to it's like
you know what i'm going to do when i
never do it i'm going to put on like a
suit
i never wear a suit to these things i
usually put them in jeans and a decent
shirt but i'm going to wear a suit
up you got snazzy i got [ __ ] i got i
became a fancy lad
um last night it was a fancy lad and
then i showed up at this movie premiere
and they were like uh okay uh walk this
way we're gonna we're gonna start with
the red carpet over here wait why am i
on the red carpet i don't understand
what's happening here i just came to
celebrate the the launch of this year
fine motion picture well you know
there's people who want to talk to me
into the carpet they got to take your
picture i was like do they realize
that i don't have any lines in this
movie
just doesn't matter um
but yeah so i went to the premiere of
clerks three last night
oh my god clerks iii sounds like a
sequel to a classic uh 90s
cinematic hallmark of independent film
uh
i was like a sequel to the to the to the
mid-2000s
um
somewhat studio cash in on that original
sounds like the director is just like
i'm poor again i need a fresh influx of
cash let me hit the clerk's atm
every 10 years papa's got to eat
up to him i know how he feels
um
i too went to that screening kids with
mr mark bernardin uh not with him but i
was there as well
uh and it was absolutely lovely we had
the clerk's three uh premiere yesterday
at the chinese theater down right down
the hill for me and then we had a party
afterwards over at the roosevelt hotel
which was
expansive like
really through a big party big shindig
lionsgate has been absolutely wonderful
to work with this entire time marketing
campaign like i got to meet the guy who
cut the trailer
at bond last night he was like i cut the
trailer and i was like did you produce
it he's like i'm literally the editor
and i gave him a big hug and stuff
because i was like that that's the only
reason people are going to go see the
movies because they see that [ __ ]
trailer and that trailer is so good
um
yeah it was it was a really lovely night
the thing that i don't know why i was
surprised by this but
rosario was there
i just always assume people like rosario
you know are [ __ ] shooting four
movies at once
and you know don't necessarily have the
time to break off for [ __ ] like this but
she showed up lent our premiere a bunch
of class and elegance and whatnot uh and
such a like a team player man she was
like she hadn't seen the flick she had a
link to watch it online like a long time
ago but she was like i'm gonna watch it
on the big screen
so she got to experience the whole thing
last night and she loved it man but she
was so like afterwards she pulled me
aside and she was like i thought it was
the perfect blend of clerks and clerks
too and she started going through points
about him like we're at the premiere man
we're friends don't like you're
analyzing the movie like but she's
she as much as she's in the franchise
she's a fan
of the french she's very geeky and uh we
are something of a geeky franchise so it
was lovely uh that she showed up today
i got to meet
her time
yeah i hadn't met her before last night
and so i did the thing where there's
she's the queen in her court and so i
just waited for my moment to go and
introduce and it says hey i just wanted
to say hi you know we have a couple of
mutual friends and they tried to connect
this to do splinter there was you know
while there i i was trying to see if she
could do splinter but couldn't do it for
reasons that eventually became clear
she's in in all of the star wars uh a
light saber right there
that was your lightsaber um but then i
also i we we tried you know you had
mentioned it to me and then an unusual
friend was like she really wants to be a
stranger
she would love to be in a [ __ ] star
trek i'm like well it just so happens
that i'm working on a star trek show and
we tried to get her and started it but
once again her schedule just didn't
allow for it to happen but she's a deep
[ __ ] nerd and uh and for the 48
seconds that i got to talk to her it was
all about nerd [ __ ] and that was lovely
um she's a wonderful human being and god
did she look stunning last night but uh
so did you so much so that this morning
in the daily mail
a british newspaper
because i don't know if you know this or
not kids but mark's huge in london
they had photos of you know famous
people and [ __ ] and one of those [ __ ]
famous people was a very dapper mark
and they have the thing where they put
him up in his picture and they break
down his outfit and [ __ ] yes they had to
write a caption because
it was like looking sharp
in a grey and black
suit
is mark bernhard
i had no idea we had so much celebrity
in him i would have put more of you in
the trailer [ __ ]
less rosario more of the other guy
dapper dan in the corner um it was so
lovely though uh what a great [ __ ]
time and and uh
you know i'm not a big premier uh person
because it feels like we're giving the
movie away for free like
we didn't work this hard to just give
away the movie like this did we
um i like people who pay to see the
movie because they they're invested you
know what i'm saying like some of these
cats just came to take pictures um at a
premiere party or something like that
so normally the premieres are kind of
like
something you dutifully or i dutifully
do i'm not a partier i don't [ __ ]
drink so none of it is appealing to me
think about it like there's gonna be a
party with booze and you gotta show your
movie for free to people who probably
don't wanna see it
none of this [ __ ] works for me
but last night's was uh was really warm
and wonderful and uh mercifully uh
lionsgate was let us bring in 150 like
real people wow a lot of people from
that kevin smith club
um
came to the premiere and then party
afterwards
so
there were there was a contingency of
real people in the audience um who are
real invested in the ongoing story of
clerks
and um
the thing [ __ ] played insanely well
especially considering it was a premiere
so much so that i was like this is how
it plays here
like i cannot wait to get on the road
and we head out on the road of course
for the convenience tour a week
from sunday uh september 4th that kicks
off at bank new jersey and then crosses
the country if you can't see it with me
see it at a fathom event screening from
september 13th to 18th uh tickets for
all of this at clerks3.movie but
watching it with the audience i don't
sit i sat for the very like two first
two minutes of the credits and then ran
to the back of the auditorium and
watched it from like the back exit
hallway
where it's just you're seeing it like
kind of like this
um
because you know you're bracing like
your asshole's tight you're like
i hope they [ __ ] like it and stuff
and they really did they really went for
it it's a funny movie but it's a very
emotional movie as well and that's the
thing that most people don't expect when
they head into it's like says clerks
like oh boy i can't wait to laugh and
you will laugh but you're going to feel
some things as well by the end of the
picture
so um it was uh from a guy who spent
most of his life you know lingering in
the back of movie theaters of films he's
made
counting the laughs or counting on
the laughs you know hearing silence
during my screenings is usually a deadly
proposition
um last night hearing silence where i
wanted it
was just almost musical
at them
like you know so much so that when the
movie was over and
the movie ends proper kids but then
i found more real estate to stick my
[ __ ] voice like as if my voice isn't
heard enough for the movie not this
voice like obviously silent bob has a
line or two but
uh the voice of kevin smith as much as
it's all my perspective all my voice but
i found real estate during the credits
where i was like
i should put up more talking and and so
and the end credits i talk you through
the to the end credits and um it's uh
a little bit pointy what i talk about
and people
responded to that in such a big bad way
in this way that like i bumped into
where somebody was like that's my
favorite part of the film i was like
it's literally the end
it's
not even part of the film it's the
credits and like yeah but it ties it
together so well and stuff so the
director kevin smith the filmmaker was
just like
how could that be your favorite part but
the you know egocentric kevin smith
whose voice it is was like of course
it's your favorite part it's my favorite
part too it's the guy makes the most
sense he's so clear-cut and [ __ ] like
it's the most like a podcast of the
entire movie exactly
so i right after the screening was done
i jumped in a car
and uh took off to go grab smoke before
the party and stuff by myself and just
had that moment i don't know if other
artists ever have this or other people
who make stuff
other creatives but
there's a moment where you
you're like holy [ __ ] that worked like
it's a long process
and you're never quite done but there is
a moment where you realize like
i think i did the thing that i set out
to do which is not just like hey we made
a movie but it's like
i think i think that
i think i'm going to manipulate their
feelings with this movie you know it
used to be about making them laugh now
it's about making them laugh and then
also
feel some [ __ ]
uh so it was it was wonderful then i
went back to the party i saw mark i saw
a bunch of cats uh took pictures with
everybody uh it was
absolutely lovely man such a good time
and not the [ __ ] first time i got
dressed up
that week
i noticed the best was out
it's true man i for a guy who hasn't
dressed up in a long time
i had two
quasi-dress outfits this week um
one for uh of course the clerk's uh
three premiere last night and the other
this weekend
uh for a wedding that a friend of mine
had which is something that i was doing
with the junket for clerks 3 on tuesday
and a junket is where you sit in one
space and then they file journalists in
front of you so i talked to
50 60 people over the course of a few
hours sitting in one chair and some of
them were online or zoom and some of
them were there in person and stuff
and um over the course of uh all that
uh talking [ __ ] i hit a pothole [ __ ]
what was i gonna say it was a good point
um was it about the wedding you went to
yes thank you yeah every one of those
uh uh journalists
you know were very sweet about like so
clerks three you're back in the in the
gang and and it's based on your heart
attack and you know and but then
they get ten minutes
by the eight minute mark every every
journalist was like
so
and right then an area like here comes
and they're like you know i
i
hate to ask but
we heard you went to a wedding this
weekend and stuff so uh there was a lot
of
that and so there's a guy in the junket
room who ran one of the cameras who at
the break after four hours of interviews
he was like
it's such a weird phenomenon to watch
somebody be asked repeatedly about a
wedding that he was not
a part of
like he's like they're all asking you
about the wedding like it was your
wedding and he's like that's so straight
is it strange for you
and i was like
you know i understand but like it's not
my story to give details on i can't tell
them like
this is what they serve this is what
they said this is who was here that's
for ben and jen to share
but i could give him my perspective
which was like oh my god i cried it was
beautiful i never seen one of my oldest
friends i've never seen him happier
in his life and vice versa like you know
his
pure magic make i'm telling you that
[ __ ] wedding would have made the
coldest
most cynical heart
believe in [ __ ] true love it was so
beautiful
but it was strange like
to be there talking about
you know
here's this third movie in 30 years
that sprang from this little black and
white movie years ago and stuff
like more than enough [ __ ] to talk about
and still of course people were like
so
[Laughter]
did they even bother to connect it with
like
so we saw the movie
and we know that there's a scene and
there's some cameos or whatever
can you tell me about one of the like
and just finding the ways the percentage
of people that were like so ben's in
this movie
that was the other way into the comments
and then of course i was like oh yes
ben's in the movie and that's when they
would follow up at the wedding but um
there were a few definitely a handful a
handful who were more nuanced about and
this is not a complaint i don't want
this to be like smith obliterates
journalists for doing their job not at
all i completely like understand
but at a certain point it was like um
you know we do things to pass the time
at our job
time make it go by faster
it was a certain like game of my own my
internal game all day long to be like
somebody who hit the chair and be like i
i would try to predict in my head at one
minute out of the ten
the wedding wouldn't
come up
um but it was good everyone like
even
i'm not going to say in spite of that
because that was not hard it was very
easy to talk about how how lovely things
were um
but
the amount of
good will for lack of a better word that
i would
say that
we've been feeling toward this movie
over the course of the last week as the
world now starts seeing it because the
press is getting links and being able to
watch it at home and stuff
uh has been overwhelming it's i counting
my chickens and [ __ ] like that but like
it feels very good very very outstanding
you deserve it you may have made a hell
of a picture oh look who's here is
batman himself everybody jc what's up
bam bam so
i
went to a premiere last night as well
um they had two in town
uh unlike mark i did have
lines in the movie which i won't spoil
but i was i heard can i can i believe
not the lines but i believe there's
another moment
when the scum and villainy logo came up
and i literally heard somebody go whoa
like and i was like that has to be jc
it wasn't me there's literally
so i looked at we were assigned seating
and so i looked at my ticket and i was
like row p
row p don't they know i
i worked on this movie
and then i got in my seat and i was
sitting behind
uh liz destro and i was like this is one
of the better seats i'm sitting behind
the producer wonderful
and then
uh there was uh there's a
tiny little like
look at the wrong part of the screen and
you'll miss it scum and villainy cameo
and one person in the audience shouted
which
made me that was my favorite part of the
premiere
that had to be from the like you were
sitting in ropey because i think all the
first fros were folks real ass people
like yeah
fans and stuff uh and folks from that
kevin smith club so definitely one of
those
cats was one that
spotted it although wouldn't it be weird
to find out it was like danny trejo or
something like that
where is it
[Laughter]
but uh
we did i i don't think it's spoiling
anything we did uh some like adr stuff
like at the very end i feel like the
movie was done
and i'm the worst actor in the world and
you're like come in and do some adr
stuff
and i was like okay and i did it and i
got my car he's like there's no way
that's ever going to be in the movie
and there it was in [ __ ] dolby atmos
700 speaker sound my voice i was like oh
my gosh
recognize it right away like a [ __ ]
dog when a dog hears like
like
what happened
i heard it and she was sitting here and
i was like
and she was just like of course
that's just
give her a chance i didn't even give her
a chance um
but uh my
kind of takeaway from it because i've
seen the movie
i've seen every version of that movie
the only one i hadn't seen was
uh the final sound mix of it which is
where my voice got put in
but i saw every other version so i've
seen it hundreds of times and the whole
drive home jen who has never seen clerks
two who watch clerks for the first time
during the pandemic
was she talked about the movie the whole
way home
so
for me
that was the measure of
like
somebody who
didn't have a nostalgia for any of it
where like what exists you know from the
first minute to the last minute just
worked within itself so that was that's
that's that's
what i i took away from it is just like
holy [ __ ] that means that it was a
self-contained experience rather than
like well you you know [ __ ] you have
to like these movies in order to dot
that thought
that's that's a good sign so yeah so
she's already seen the movie for free so
we're [ __ ]
tell her to pay for it a couple thousand
times
[Laughter]
that is uh very sweet man tell her i
said thank you i talked to her very
briefly at the party last night and she
had told me she's like i didn't see
clerks too and i loved this and i was
like well i'm glad and insulted at the
same time
yeah my wife was saying she's like i
don't think i saw clerks too because i
don't remember
careful all right we can beep it out
yeah
i've had some of that over the way
people going like i didn't see
clerks too um which you know i'm like
look i'm happy anybody sees anything i
do instead
but
it was kind of
it was kind of interesting
uh seeing people's reaction along the
way yes there are spoilers in this
podcast by the way boys and girls or not
not anymore
spoilers
we're not hey batman uh i i'll also say
sitting in row p towards the back of the
theater
it really like there are some jokes in
there that
i would laugh at
in every test screening
and
nobody else was like
like they're just tiny little things
that like you maybe catch on the third
viewing
that really
got good laughs
last night
and that's
me feeling really good
i heard a few of them too where i was
like oh [ __ ] right on like i'm not gonna
spoil anything but uh
there's some other
people who show up who say very funny
things kind of like
just real quick and small that i think
are like some of the funniest things
that
everybody caught which made me feel good
um i too was very uh like the montage
sequence
was delightful to watch i i that's
something that like
when i wrote it and shot it it was
definitely engineered to delight the
audience but like
you know it was never something that i
really thought beyond like oh they're
gonna like this i got to hear the
audience
react to it in real time and it was just
wonderful every
new face that showed up in the audition
montage they were like
like they kept getting re-excited very
excited that was kind of it was fun for
me and i will say that
and this sounds like i'm shilling for
clerks and i don't make any residuals on
the back end so i have no reason to say
this
but the first time i mean i've watched
it in essentially like a youtube size
box
so much
that seeing it and hearing it in the
movie theater
i think makes a huge difference for
what
jokes you catch and what
you'll miss on a tiny screen with laptop
speakers so
it's very very true i noticed that as
well there's some things i heard you
know i've watched this movie
ad nauseam and sometimes i just watch
it's been done for a while so sometimes
i just sit here smoke weed and watch the
movie whenever i
want to i mean you know i made it for me
so naturally it's made to make me feel
good so whenever i'm like i feel like
feeling good i'll put this on and just
[ __ ] watch it
and i'm used to hearing it out of a tiny
laptop speaker so hearing it like
[ __ ] full mix in a theater i was like
oh [ __ ] yeah that's very loud and clear
yeah you pick up a lot that you didn't
you won't pick up necessarily at home so
fair enough uh folks in chat are like
stop talking about clerks until we all
see it fair enough we're not spoiling
anything we're just talking about
the movie in general but you're gonna
have a chance to see it folks september
4th
the convenience tour begins in new
jersey or if you can't see that version
somebody online was like you're charging
too much to see this movie
and uh on the tour and uh i found like
honestly the cheapest ticket is 37 bucks
it's really
it's if you go to see me by myself
without a movie it's the same price so
this is like going to see me live and
then hey guess what we throw in a
[ __ ] free movie essentially so uh but
if that is like outside
uh or i'm nowhere near you outside the
realm of possibility and or because i'm
nowhere near you with the tour
the fathom events screenings uh will be
happening of course starting september
13th and going every night until
september 18th including a friday and
saturday night which makes me feel like
a big boy filmmaker again i feel like i
feel like a marvel filmmaker not kevin
smith more kevin feige than anything
else um so it's coming kids clerks is
coming so hard uh it's it's like this
oh yeah
do it
um all right shall we uh
we should probably do a show we should
maybe do a show and probably kick off
the show as you know kids
is
not
uh
possible without a grant from the helena
rubinstein foundation
and viewers like you
[Laughter]
and the letter b
oh my god we got to talk about that
right sesame street going away from i
know it happened a week ago but like
yeah we'll hit that later on but uh no
we don't have helena rubinstein doesn't
like either me or mark bernard
uh they they said hell in a handbasket
with those [ __ ] but we had to go find
money not from public
sources but we had to go find money from
our good sponsors here at uh at uh fat
man beyond and we got two this week and
the very first sponsor the one that's
gonna sponsor the whole first half of
the show
the good old friends of ours man uh i'm
not gonna tell you who it is
uh which is goes against the principle
of advertising altogether
i'm taking a bold new approach to sales
kids
but i'm gonna read you the first line of
their copy
i'm gonna let you guess
who tonight's sponsor is ready who are
you gonna read it as he's gonna do is
kevin smith gonna put some spin on it
i'm gonna put some spin on it here we go
it's not gonna work as well this is only
good when i have a microphone but here
comes bain
from tom hardy's bane kids an impression
from 10 years ago
i'm as current as a saturday night live
sketch and [ __ ] finger right on the
poles
here's bane reading
the headline of our sponsor
smooth sock summer that's a terrible
band i need a microphone to do it
uh smooth sack summer
who do you think our sponsor is mark uh
hacky sack
good guess
wilson's
this is not gonna be another one of
those birthday candles situation is it
we're going to win final jeopardy this
time
yes we're going to the next round god
damn it
kids if it's smooth sack summer
it can only be our good friends at
manscape that's right the good folks at
manscape why don't you roll over to uh
get uh 20 off uh plus free shipping uh
with the cone uh the code fatman20 at
manscape.com go to manscaped.com
m-a-n-s-c-a-p-e-d dot com right now as
i'm talking man because when you order
you're gonna get 20 off plus free
shipping with the code fatman20 that's
how much they like us here at this show
they sponsor us they gave us our own
[ __ ] code
you hear that we're using code names
can i be smooth
you are smooth sex that's our new
character our new comic book character
remember the sad sack comics from back
in the day of the
ripoff beetle bailey well smooth sack is
a modern equivalent
i'll be smooth sack and you'd be ball
preserver and together
dude we got a [ __ ] show right here we
could pitch this get netflix on the line
it's smooth sex summer boys
did you know that
did you mark did you know it was smooth
sack summer i i i was not
i was not on that memo but i'm glad to
know now nobody [ __ ] alerted me hell
yeah it's smooth sex time this whole
time i've been harry sachs summer
again what's my problem if you haven't
heard already kids at smooth sack summer
when you're playing in the summer sun
make sure you're escaped
from pubes to bum
like these guys to the [ __ ]
yep is that part of it
i mean it can be when you manscape are
they advocating the the clearing of the
[ __ ] as well
i think it's a personal choice just how
much i mean i'm not against it i just it
never occurred to me
in my mind manscaped was always about
your pubes and [ __ ] but like that's
right men got hairy asses i guess an ass
could be part of this equation
yeah i mean no reason not to baby butt
that [ __ ] if you can
you know you know how you get two asses
done uh with a manscape shaver at once
they go ass to ass
remember that movie
i'm just now imagining like the man's
gay people are like excellent reading an
advertisement i wonder what they'll
he's got a movie coming right [ __ ] uh
the dude who did i asked to ask uh what
was it called the what was that um
uh god what was it called the one letto
and jennifer conley it was so depressing
oh yeah the darren aronofsky that was a
requiem for a dream requiem that's the
ass to ass movie um he's uh he's got
another movie coming with brendan
frazier the whale did you see an image
from it no is he stuck in a whale's dick
what's happening i mean
that might be the only way this movie
could possibly be more interesting
based from what i've seen it's about
brendan fraser he packed down some
weight to play the role and then they
put prosthetics on him he's playing a
very very large dude and the toronto
film festival they're giving them an
award before the festival begins for
this aronofsky movie it is called the
whale instantly jumped onto my must-see
list man because i'm like that's
brave and bold and the story sounds like
a very heavyset dude reconnecting with
his kid or something like that but
you know aronofsky is a pretty
interesting [ __ ] filmmaker uh to say
the least so i i suddenly look forward
to this however we're here to talk about
manscape i mean you're doing ad for
darren aronofsky unless darren aronofsky
is the kind of guy that likes
if he's taking part in in smooth sack
summer
then yes
all i'll say is i did not see
the sequel to noah being called the
whale
um but okay
yeah he's crossing over man he forgot
that it's jonah not knowing
um that's right this summer to keep your
balls cool while you're still looking
hot
do it with manscape kids please don't do
it with anyone else do not let anybody
else touch your balls just manscape the
leader and below the belt
or a doctor
yes
um they're making sure that we all have
a ball this summer naked ball if you
will by giving our pants partners
everything they need to stay fresh dive
head first
into smooth sack summer these guys are
good by going to manscape.com for 20 off
plus free shipping with our code fat man
20. i believe we have a testimonial this
week mark we do tell us about your balls
banff man hey banff man don't you've got
some experience with this landscape
yeah i uh
this i did this on saturday
that's manscaped
right
here
that's the i think i lawn mowered it i
think that's the lawn mower
4.0 trimmer yeah the 4.0 that i took
across the side and that's i mean it's
pretty good like this is a week of
growth so it was even closer
why um the uh so what you're telling us
here if i follow your story
is that uh the manscape shaver is good
for
uh your head as well as your bottom it
is
multi-use
your most important of all
any hair that grows around either of
your heads
you can use the lawnmower on
um smithson 16 in chat says smooth as a
whale to tie
nice she escaped and aronofsky together
man
he lifted my mind and heart right now
um banff man when we all this time we've
been doing manscape did you understand
it to mean like ass hair as well
uh
no i didn't think about it but
it works it seems like it would make
sense yeah yeah like what if you're like
robin williams on your butt man like he
was very hairy you ever see his you take
his shirt off he's he had a hairy chest
um this would be a way to clear up the
cheeks as well and inside the cheek look
i ain't going to tell you how to use
your razor kids
but it's occurring to me that it's good
for more than one shape as we can see
based on jc mark's used it on his head
as well i have indeed during the
pandemic it was my solution to not
having access to a barber
how's my own damn barber look at that
[ __ ] look shave whatever you want with
the good folks at manscape man smooth
sack summer
don't [ __ ] forget we love these
manscape folks man the the the uh
the trimmer
is waterproof so that means you can use
it around your ass you got watery assets
like i do
the lawn did you use the lawnmower 4.0
uh
banff man to uh trim that hair you think
i did it's lawn mower i did it i hung a
mirror in our shower
and i looked in the mirror and just did
it
did it while i was
bathing
but it was better travis [ __ ] bickle
yeah well it was
[Laughter]
it was better because it's easy cleanup
in the shower
like all the hair just goes in it down
the drain and you grab it out of the
drain whereas if i did it in the
bathroom
i have to get the vacuum and it's like
trying to pick up glitter it just never
works right
i'm trying not to i mean
all of the words that you just said are
also
applicable to just masturbating
it's like it's like glitter everywhere
it's better in the shower where the
cleanup is easier and i used a mirror so
i could see myself when i was doing it
like i like to make eye contact i don't
give a [ __ ] who it's with
i gotta feed the eyes i need to see the
eyes to come
don't come until you see the mic i'm
gonna die
i [ __ ] like a revolutionary war soldier
one shot and then it takes me 90 minutes
to reload
one thing only
oh we're having a good time during
smooth sax summer kids
good old times thanks sir our sponsor at
manscape go right now go now as uh
hannibal lecter screamed at uh clarice
starling uh get 20
off plus free shipping with the code
fatman20 at manscaped with a d at the
end dot com that's 20 off what are you
[ __ ] nuts plus free shipping with the
code
fat man 20 fat man and 2-0 all together
at
manscaped.com it's a smooth sack summer
boys and girls you're invited
uh get on board or get left behind it's
that simple
don't you want to be part of the sheeran
shorn sac crowd like me and mark
i want to be a part of i wonder what
would happen if i just like showed my
wife like
you know
i finally i broke down with the
lawnmower and i got rid of all these
unsightly hairs and this is what my
testicles look like unencumbered love
meet the boys
see them bye
aren't they so much prettier now should
be like ah
this one's name is crooked
i don't know anybody that likes balls
there you go put that on my [ __ ]
tombstone i don't know everybody likes
balls
manscaped i don't know anybody that
likes me
yeah we just lost manscape this is a
sponsor like you know everyone loves
balls from now on you hear me silent
bill
bob whatever
you know manscape's logo i don't have
one here it's a
it's uh
testicles that form a heart right
are you [ __ ] me it's it's look at
their thing it's like a heart
but like upside down so that
the bottom of the heart is balsa i've
been seeing it on the copy that's
hysterical
guys are good
that first paragraph was the best ad
copy we've ever had
yeah i'm just saying this means that
some are strong they really do yeah i
look
i'm just sorry that i missed a majority
of smooth sex summer but now i know
what i'm living for
smooth sack summer 2023 mark
it's coming
it's my burning man
my coachella
it's smooth sack summer 2023
having a ball
2023
don't testies me
[Laughter]
um all right folks uh we thank the good
folks at uh at manscape man as always uh
for
sponsoring this silliness so we could
talk about the [ __ ] that really matters
uh
i guess we should start with uh reviews
shall we yeah let's do that we got we
got three things to talk about before we
get into the news
where would you like to start my friend
i would like to start with robin
brownfield in the chat who said this ad
is taking too long
come on robin
that's not the spirit
now robin we'll extend this ad for
another 40. yeah guess what
10 more stories
about
about smooth sack summer
yeah you like that robin you just
brought yourself another saturday you
want another one you want to go for more
mess with the bullet you get the horns
uh what should we lead with let's talk
about the sandman bonus episode which
came the [ __ ] out of nowhere uh
netflix kids and it is amazing about it
last episode uh both of us blew it
pretty hard
uh it is a gorgeous uh it is fun to
watch with people who are completely
unfamiliar with the original comic book
material uh because it's like seeing it
through fresh eyes people discovering
one of the most imaginative stories
ever told you know i enjoyed sitting
there watching it with uh my wife who'd
never seen or read the sandman and
watching her be like this is [ __ ]
incredible and being like yeah sure was
30 years ago when we all first read it
slowpoke you know feeling superior it's
kind of show that makes you feel morally
superior
people you're married to and others and
[ __ ] so
you know we all on this show consumed it
[ __ ] fast and you know we're done and
we're like can't wait for [ __ ] season
two and thought we'd have to wait for a
potential season two which we'll talk
about in a second however
out of nowhere
they just popped in at episode 11 up
like [ __ ] just
surprise
dreams in the summer
um it was the combination dream of a
thousand cats which was an animated
episode
based on the issue of the comic the same
name
and then uh also the calliope uh
storyline about the the captured muse
who is uh you know
forced to give stories to the series of
writers who take her hostage and who is
the former
spoilers the former wife
of dream himself
um i could see why they didn't include
this
in the season proper because it was too
many detours from the story they were
trying to tell
but my god what a welcome addition it
was like a what do they call it when you
get is aperitif when something's after
the meal
um yes aperitif
what a [ __ ] apparent teeth this was
man like we thought we were done and
suddenly they're like sherbert [ __ ]
that sherbert was
a dream of a thousand cats which is a
beautifully
beautifully animated a version of the
story of uh a cat who tells the about
meeting the lord of dreams and and tells
this like wonderful story about an down
world where cats once ruled and man did
not mankind humankind until they dream
you know of it they dream of of the
reverse of of cats being small and
humans being big uh it's a incredibly
charming towel if you're a cat lover at
all it's a must-see
i applaud the uh them not making their
mouths move
yeah like there's there's a way to do it
it's the aristocats and you know it's
fun we've seen that version of a
thousand times yeah but the idea that
cats are also telepathic which does sort
of dovetail into
the weirdness of cats um
anyway and and also like trigger warning
if you're an animal lover it does get
grisly at times like there's there's
there's you know it's about the story of
this you know sort of young kitten who
you know finally gets to leave her her
people's house for the first time to go
out and listen to this traveler tell the
tale and part of the traveler's tale is
how she became the person who left her
people who she thought took care of her
and she you know and not again not to
spoil too much but her story begins with
tragedy begins with love beginning and
then in terms of tragedy and then turns
to resolve of
i want the answer as to why this could
happen to me and the only person who had
the answer for her was morpheus the lord
of dreams and it's yeah it's gorgeous
and beautiful and the voice cast is
astonishing and
you know and the fact that yeah they
pulled off a secret animated episode of
the show and nobody knew about it you
know and even apparently you know i read
this interview with neil gaiman who said
that
like
10 months ago he dropped in some
interview that they had cast some actors
to play the cats but then nobody ever
followed up i'm like well where was the
cast he was like yeah i think he
mentioned that like you know
a couple of the performers and nobody
put those two things together so they
did come out of nowhere
wow man um it's as beautiful as it is
it's a sumptuous cartoon uh insanely
well done and uh
like all of the sandman just imaginative
as
[ __ ] and like all the same mana story
i've been familiar with for decades but
seeing it played out and rediscovering
its charms um
you know
cats they're [ __ ] adorable but like
you know that i think i was on joe rogan
once and he was just like if a cat was
five times its size it would [ __ ]
kill you just as soon as you know it
would
it would rub on your legs they're just
so capricious and [ __ ] deadly and
[ __ ] like that and this episode played
with that notion
quite well uh but it also did as mark
pointed out uh have the bummer of like
yeah people they suck um like a huge cat
lover and i was like hey man you gotta
watch this i showed her some images and
but i had to give her the heads up where
i was like but there is one part that
you're gonna have to get past and she's
like i'm not doing it then
come on it's so worth it and she's like
nope nope
um and calliope was [ __ ] achingly
beautiful as well they changed the story
a little bit some people said online i
don't remember uh
one
change yeah the story as as with much of
the sandman
um
lots especially the first sort of pro of
it a lot lots of it is in that kind of
third person narration where it was you
know neil gaiman's voice says author
just telling you what's happening
and so when you first meet richard
maddock you know and and the captions
you know he's the author who has all the
written one book that had sort of
remarkably decent reviews and has
renaming since and is trying to find
the
the solution the key the shortcut to
being able to realize and write his
second book and he tracks down an author
named erasmus fry
who in exchange for a particularly
grisly bit of medical oddity
um agrees to hand over the secret of how
he's writing these stories and the
secret is he had kidnapped a muse one of
the actual
legit greek mythological muses named
calliope
and imprisoned her and and took her gift
by force
you know they never they never
actually come out and say
rape
even though that is what the book says
happened
the book is very clear about you know he
he
he brought gladly home
he put her in in
a chamber and he raped her that's in the
comic book that's a comic book like in
its text says this is what richard
maddock does because that's how you get
the gift from goliath either she gives
it freely or you take it by force and
it's sexual force
so that
did you get that impression from the i
mean it was very tastefully done then in
in the netflix version because it wasn't
clear if he was just going in there and
pounding or if he was i i that hadn't
even occurred to me but oh my god
yeah and like that it's it's it's as
tasteful as you can possibly do it
it is i mean absolutely but because it's
like so much so that i was unaware of it
completely
yeah like she says she said well erasmus
took it from me by force and you you
think i'll respond by these gifts
because she brings you like
pretty clothes and dresses and candies
and perfumes and all that stuff and she
refuses and so then they cut to him at
his keyboard and like there's a there's
a tiny gash on his face that looks like
from a fingernail i remember there's a
blood thing yeah
you know so
only because i remember the original
book am i intimating that that is the
response for the result the fallout from
that act of taking it
well
by
force
he starts writing and then he [ __ ]
goes for it and so it's it's taking the
stuff out of the third person and making
it first person and making it
um you know active dialogue on the part
of the characters that that's the entire
trick of adaptation of sandman
and the reasons why i think stories like
calliope and the junior thousand cats
are in this sort of adjunct form
is because they're not dream stories
they're not a boundary dream is an
incidental character in both of these
stories and the show previously has been
very much about dream's art it's very
much about his story and what he's
learning and what he's discovering about
himself and about the world and about
his effect on people
um
so i kind of like being finding the way
to retain these kind of one-offs these
little anthological short stories
which dream is is is a passerby it's a
bystander sometimes or
just a person somebody turns to for help
and not the actual mover of the story
tell you man
like
i guess it's a weird thing to confess
but i think i'm pretty stupid like i'm
clever clever enough to have like the
career i've got but like
i sometimes i watch a thing and i just
don't see it and at all and then like
sometimes i'll turn to my wife and be
like i i don't get it and then she
explains it and i'm like
what was that right how did i not
[ __ ] see that
and um there's a bunch of people in chat
who are like how did you miss that you
know meaning the the implied
uh assault of the of calliope
um
i don't know i'm not very i guess i'm
not very good at watching things
but you know what i'm saying like i i'm
just
maybe i'm like a idiot savant like i
can't
i can't ingest it but i could make it i
i don't know like
now that like now when you talk about it
i'm like oh my god because now all of a
sudden i'm like oh that's
there's all sorts of levels of metaphor
in that and
maybe i've just lived long enough
forgotten to be fair i haven't read the
comics since
like i read the comics and then probably
re-read them like a year later or
something like that
but i got to get smarter mark
is it is it too late to get smart i'm
52. like i feel like the window is
closed but i how do i get i know most
people be like stop smoking as much weed
as you do perhaps that'll help but i
can't do that so what else could i do
to get a little more astute
like i'm not going to do that part but
give me a magic pill i can take that'll
loosen up the brain juice
i also feel too that i'm very like an up
with people person so i don't
see like you know the bad right away and
[ __ ] you know like i'm the kind i
watched star wars and
for a long time i was like oh you know
this darth vader's just misunderstood
[Laughter]
you know [ __ ] jaws i was always like
he's just hungry he's a hungry monster i
mean he's just an animal he does what he
does i i like giving people and
characters particularly fictional the
benefit of the doubt and [ __ ] but
i think i've got to get more rigorous
with my
with my
consumption i got to become like film
twitter where it's like
nah don't do that we gotta know oh i got
it i'm gonna
watch me
the thing that's so weird like collabi
is one of my favorite issues of sandman
and and i don't know what that says
about me
um other than especially because it
fundamentally hates writers
like it does not cast writers in a very
good light which is so
so funny because he is one of the unless
he's hiding some secret dark heart
neil is one of the sweetest nicest
people in the world and one of the best
writers but you're right there's a lot
of like self say not not like self agent
like neil hates himself but there's a
lot of writer bashing in his work
i mean it's got my one of my favorite
lines in the whole book where i think
it's erasmus fry and then later richard
maddox says
writers are liars my dear like don't
believe a word we say even on the page
or something like that maybe neil's
trying to communicate something right on
front street he's just like
some cute british [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm dark like morpheus yeah
i'm
dangerous too opens up his hand and
gives you that [ __ ] nobody wants
uh
i love him though i'm so happy for him
uh
because everyone's responding to it so
positively i i mean i don't read
everything obviously but everything
that's come across
my timelines and my socials is effusive
praise for it i know he's he's number
one in every country
um
and it couldn't happen to a nicer guy or
again [ __ ] being nice like reward strong
imagination this [ __ ] had these
dreams
30 years ago
kept them preserved nobody else did them
and then [ __ ] got to put them up on
the screen like straight from his head
and heart like i'm so happy for him
however
did i or did i not see
i know it's probably a news thing but
while we're here
did he say that there's a possibility it
might not come back to netflix
i mean
what what he said was i think was in a
rolling stone interview you know that
first off like they're all hoping for a
season two he's like netflix has been
incredibly supportive of it
um but it's an expensive show i mean the
the tweet he put out was because sandman
is really expensive for netflix to
release the money to make another season
we have to perform incredibly well so
yes we've been the top show in the world
for two weeks but that still might not
be enough
um because it said because of the price
because of the price and they never said
what it what it is
right they've never revealed the budget
but one has to imagine it's
maybe not lord of the rings because
nothing is but
how much is lord of the rings per
episode
um
we're not sure i mean the the word was
they were about 250
260 million dollars for the first season
uh many episodes
i think it's probably ten maybe it's
eight but either way
it's an insane amount of money so that's
like easily 25 million dollars per
episode 25 30 million per episode
i read that it was lord of the rings was
five times as expensive as
house of dragon
for game of thrones
so i think i think lord of the rings was
500 i think it was house of dragons is
about a hundred hundred and fifty
that's what i mean
so then where do you get crazy
where do you think uh
a sandman is in that same range higher
um i don't think it's that high i mean i
don't think netflix is spending that
kind of money
you know like maybe they're spending it
on stranger things because they know
it's [ __ ] stranger things
you know i know they spent you know
somewhere between 15 and 17 million
dollars on episodes of the crown
you know and so is it in that range
maybe
could be
um
even though one of those episodes is
sent a diner and like some of these are
bottle episodes like the the sound of
her wings is generally a relatively
cheap episode to do because there's two
people talking in a part
but then you've got to go to hell and
and they went they didn't shoot on the
volume like they did almost all of that
stuff
practically with green screens but like
we're going to castles we're going to
[ __ ] abandoned churches we're doing
all this stuff
and so it ain't cheap and and yeah i
read the rolling stone piece that he did
you know we talked about that there's a
thing in the contract
that they signed with netflix saying
they wanted the ability to make sure
that that they could complete the
sandman story
and so that if netflix decides they
don't want to make it anymore because
for whatever reason they had a
contractual out to then be able to take
the show someplace else
um
nobody wants that to happen i don't
think neil does because i think he's
been very happy
um noreen allen heimberg is a showrunner
and david goyer another producer they
would like to say netflix and make a
show
but um
but who knows the other thing that i
found interesting in that in that
rolling stone piece was that he talked
about when it was a feature that john
peters at one point was going to to be
the producer of it who wanted a giant
mechanical spider
in
in a in sandman and saw that that's true
a lot of people have been tweeting that
out like did you see this [ __ ]
he's still up to
the gold spidery trick
yeah he talk about a man with a vision
one vision
singular vision
[ __ ] a man in his dream
hold that tiger hold the tiger giant
spider oh that spider
uh
it's deep cuts when you're doing tucker
references my friends but i'm here for
it yeah thank you you're a child of the
70s and 80s just like me see you know
we were seeing tucker at a time where we
weren't in the business
we were just like i like this couple of
fella and i like this jeff bridges guy
from the king kong movie i said
they've got a future remember that was
it wasn't like uh lucas involved in that
too because they
i think so they had the car they all had
tuckers or something like that yeah i
don't know if i don't know if it was a
lucasfilm production but i think george
lucas definitely had a hand and
um all right so kids watch the extra
episode of sandman man if you haven't
seen it yet watch all of sandman but you
could literally just watch the 11th
episode without having seen anything
before and it stands alone by itself
mostly the clyopic one you need a little
bit of history on the character
um
she-hulk
she-hulk i've seen one i haven't seen
two yet shulky as we used to call her in
the comic books kids uh she-hulk uh
starring tatiana maslany is that how
he's
well played what a charming uh little
sitcom that marvel has put together i
enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it i thought it
was fun um i think uh her talking to the
camera i know a lot of people are like
oh man that's deadpool but no that's
straight out of [ __ ] the comics when
john byrne was doing the character
um
it's fun it's them kind of having fun
with themselves uh being able to
poke fun at themselves and their world
expanding the marvel universe
comedically you know it's all humor has
always been a big part of marvel
cinematic universe this just leans into
it more heavily than anything else um i
i've you know i know some people in the
beginning were like oh that's cg but
you know this is an unreal character so
i i don't really have any basis for
comparison to be like well that's not
what a real she-hulk looks like
um
to me it's just impressive like watching
like
so much of that show your lead character
is a huge walking talking special effect
like
not since alf
has a sitcom or you know or maybe max
headroom has a sitcom spent so much on
its
getting presenting its lead character
um but i've i enjoyed it i think uh
the sense of humor totally works for me
um the uh you know that we got a lot of
[ __ ] we got a lot more [ __ ]
hulk than we've had in recent memory
and it looks like they're setting us up
for
spoilers
like world war hulk on the side of this
it sounds it feels like they are
backdoor leading to a hulk standalone
series
um and it might be world war hulk that's
what i'm getting from like the amount
that they're including
uh bruce banner uh smart hulk if you
will
uh i watched the second episode right
before we started the show my only
complaint was it was [ __ ] light bro
it's like 23 minutes
wow yeah i mean that's like the length
of an alph and uh it's got one
post-credits scene and [ __ ] but um that
didn't really propel the story forward
it was more just humorous but yeah it
was a very short second episode
um you know as per usual disney puts
them out once a week so you you know
you've got something to look forward to
and [ __ ] but i'm enjoying it i think it
was a welcome ad i know right now half
the internet is probably shredding me
and calling me woke or whatever the [ __ ]
but like it has very little to do with
that and more to do with the fact that
like marvel's doing humor like they're
looking into the humor of it all and
extending their mythos you know we got
to see
a new jail
by uh the department of uh damage
control
which could figure prominently in the
future
because you got to put all these people
somewhere so
maybe they're building their arkham in
the marvel cinematic universe so to
speak with this
big old super max prison that they got
emil blonsky and that's the other thing
man you get the abomination back in this
thing and it looks like in episode two
they're they're gonna explain
how he showed up in shanghai
right which i'm for man i'm all for this
this is the interconnected you know
within the universe storytelling that i
[ __ ] adore
so um yeah i'm all about she-hulk i
thought it was really fun more of that
you
um i i love to tear missalani i
i rode so hard for her in orphan black
you know
like i was there for every emmy campaign
that she you know never got to win
um
but i think she's so immensely talented
and so i was excited to see you in the
show and i think she's she's doing good
work i mean my biggest issue
was actually too much hulk
was actually like because this stuff
i know
really too much hulk too much hope
because i there's there's no conflict at
all
in that first episode that we don't
already know how it's going to resolve
you know it's
i need to train you to do it this way
and i don't want to do it that way i
have my own way and it's just that for
like 20 minutes
it's yoga it's a fist fight that nobody
actually needs because everybody knows
who's that nobody's going to lose this
fight
you know like it's
i didn't need that much origin story
you know and and if there's anything
that i was hoping for it's more of
jessica walters discovering for herself
how to do this
um jennifer wallace jessica walters is a
late actress
jennifer long
um
you know great jessica walters delay
great jessica walden but like just have
her stumble through this [ __ ] great
american hero style i don't have a an
instruction manual on how to be a hug
and so i'm figuring it out as i go you
know and then you can have bruce show up
towards the tail end of that process
saying here's my [ __ ] instruction
menu how to be a hulk and she just says
i don't need this because i know how to
do it and then you get that great speech
which i think is probably the best part
of the episode where she says i know
exactly how to control my anger i've
been doing it since i was a girl because
the minute i
betray
my true emotions i get called you know a
heartbeat or a [ __ ] or too aggressive
or too emotional you know or
potentially get murdered by a date that
goes wrong like all of the ways in which
women have to figure out how to exist in
the world
where almost every other person they
meet could be a threat to them like all
of that is great and i love it
but i just wish that it wasn't part of
this
what seemed to be a kind of rudimentary
let's give you something you recognize
because we're afraid you won't watch the
show
bruce banner like kind of overwhelming
holiness there i'm like no i'm here for
it if it's funny and if it's smart and
if you're giving me her as a lawyer and
all of this is cool and then we just go
back to the weird island base that he
builds with tony to get to mention tony
stark's name a lot
um
you know and then the weird tag with
with with titania like what's huh what's
happening here like it all just felt
very disconnected and disjointed
in this episode in episode two they
referred to her as influencer super
villain
that was like that's interesting um this
is the episode where episode two
is where she gets hired to
um by the law firm that she was
fighting against in court it's actually
like a lawyer show as well
which is you know i'm all for it lawyer
shows work i like people that use their
mouths for a living i'm in the world
um so
like the in episode two spoilers there's
like the guy who she was
facing the firm she was facing in court
when titania shows up
like if she was working for the da's
office they lose the case because
she hulked out
and saved the jury
and then the opposite side was like well
that creates an undue
prejudice right or
yeah or a mystery and they call it
mistrial and so the da's office has to
let her go and i was like that's [ __ ]
pretty interesting what what a great
wrinkle
then the guy who who owns the firm that
she was up against the guy who had it
thrown out
like comes to offer a job because he's
like you were gonna win
and if you hadn't you know hulked out
like that like you had us dead to right
you're a great lawyer so she's like oh
my god like i'm being hired like you
know for my legal skills but then when
she gets there
he tells her like you have to conduct
law in this office as she-hulk because
you're in charge of the superhuman
division or whatever they're calling it
uh setting up the premise for the run of
the show and um
you know it's again
fun stuff
um i was never bored i was never like
what
what the [ __ ] uh bruce comes back oh i
mean not bruce but hulk comes back
uh but not it sounds like they use them
the amount that you would have preferred
they use them in episode one
but
it also they
sets up where he's going
on this um i don't know if you remember
spoilers but in episode one we saw a
spaceship from zakar
there's uh
that ain't the last you're gonna see of
a spaceship is all i'm saying yeah like
i did i did you know
hear or read somewhere that jessica gao
who was the the head writer and creative
shield
had mentioned that all of that stuff on
the oaks private island
had been pulled up from a later episode
into the pilot
and it seems as if as you say episode
two is like 23 minutes long
they just made room for that stuff on
the pilot by pushing it into episode two
because it seems as if like that's
that's that story right like i'm i'm
i've got my closing argument i'm ready
to go win this case this accident
happens with bruce
i'd come back and i'm you know i'm the
she-hulk thing i figure it out on my own
and then go back
to uh i go back to the to the courtroom
i try the case i get my thing titania
crashes in i get fired hired like that
all feels very pleasant and then the new
job the new status quo is come work for
us and that feels like the blow the
finale of your your pilot episode
you know it all like the math of it
starts to check out
like they still needed to do that but
they didn't have more episode after that
so
it all feels like a very complicated
editing job of fracturing and
commingling a bunch of different
episodes may i suggest a new side
podcast a side hustle
uh mark on marvel where every episode
you just rewrite
[Music]
whatever they're doing
[Laughter]
it's this though
but you do it until i mean sooner or
later they hire you
like at the end of the day sooner or
later they'd be like
he's
it's
right
it's cheaper this way absolutely right
yes it is cheaper this place
if we hire him he can't talk [ __ ] about
us anymore
um it was uh i'm glad they're doing this
show man i remember when they first
announced it i was like what of
everything they could do but
you know somebody said uh in chat
number one in chat the theme tonight is
people coming up with different titles
for clerks which has been very enjoyable
um like clerking john malkovich
things like that the big le clerks key
and stuff like that nice um but um a lot
of folks talking about how much they
were surprised by how much they liked it
one cat in chat said kevin is incapable
of shredding marble let me tell you if
they give me something to shred them
over
i mean you may be right i'm incapable of
shredding anything or anybody but you
know if they gave me something i really
ever wanted to complain about i might be
able to
um
but i don't know they got my number man
like
and not not really like where kevin
foggy's like you shut your [ __ ] fat
mouth
but they they do the [ __ ] that i like so
it's like i'm very inclined to
follow what they do and they don't you
know people [ __ ] at them for this but
they don't really stray far from
from their model um though chances are
i'm usually going to like whatever they
do and this was no exception it's
charmingly done
new
and um expands the universe which i'm
all for and and like yeah even the
tony references you know my [ __ ] like
just makes the world just that much
bigger and more real and part of the fun
of those tv shows is that the ability on
a weekly basis
to give you that same feeling and that
same expansion of the universe that you
get
when you go see a movie every other year
or every
six months however many they put out
right
and i did appreciate you know the the
the runner of his captain america virgin
yeah and then the solution to it which
you know apparently came from kevin
feige himself who's like yeah no he
in in his
mental cannon for steve rogers he lost
his virginity during the uso tour
i mean i guess somebody's got to think
about whether or not steve rogers is a
virgin
[Laughter]
the man's here what you got bam man did
you see
the reddit thread or whatever it was
that went crazy that it was
star-lord's grandmother
who was
the one that he lost his virginity to
yeah because like i guess there's an
off-handed mention at some point that
she was
like a dancer or something on it
i saw that and i was just and
they showed the picture of star-lord's
mom with kurt russell
um you know ego um
and then they showed that the woman at
the uso or something like that there was
some connection i breezed by it too and
i was like i'd be wonderful if the
universe was that small and
interconnected yeah steve rogers is
somehow star-lord's great-grandfather
um
yeah she-hulk man [ __ ] check it out
yeah i'm gonna keep watching it like
this is something like this is why uh
i'm glad disney plus exists because they
would never make this as a movie what
would
you know what would be the point like it
wouldn't be this it would be
you know her fighting a world-ending
[ __ ] villain or something like that
here they get to give you like
30 minutes or this week 24
minutes
of like a marvel
movie
um where they can make the story smaller
you know sometimes the complaint is
always like
you know why is why why like [ __ ] why
does everything have to be like and this
[ __ ] could end the world because it
starts being diminishing returns like we
thrill when spider-man goes after local
villains um because it's just so
you get your head around it rather than
like everyone might die again
so it's nice to have a weekly marvel
where the stakes are incredibly [ __ ]
low
um yeah
i'm here for it i'm here for it um the
last big premiere that we haven't gone
to talk about yet
was house of the dragon
now if you watched it i didn't get to
watch it yet i have indeed watched it
and uh
here's the thing kevin
uh do you like pizza or did you like
pizza
the p the kind of pizza that they made
at the game of thrones restaurant i love
it
then you'll like this pizza because it's
very much like that pizza
similar
similar pizza you know pretty much the
same toppings pretty much the same
seasoning you know they know how to make
game of thrones for you
and so now they're just giving it back
to you again
um
you know the like it's expertly realized
the cast is fantastic they're all doing
good work
the only complaint that i have about it
is that everybody is who they seem to be
and there was no surprise of very much
anything in that first episode is that
right yeah because you know and and
game of thrones specifically was very
much about
giving you these unexpected twists and
turns
even right down to the pilot which
spoilers if you haven't seen the pilot
of game of thrones at this point but the
very last scene reveals to you
that jamie lannister and cersei
lannister
brother and sister are having sex with
each other because incest all right and
then they throw young brandon stark out
of the window i remember that i remember
like being because muse had been asking
me to watch this show for two years
and finally one day i was like fine i'll
give it a shot at the end of that first
episode i was like what the [ __ ] have
you signed me up
i was like this is repugnant but i must
watch episode two but i must watch
episode two because you spend the entire
episode like all right well these two
people brother and sister whatever and
they seem rich and blah blah you just
think they're one thing and by the end
they're revealed to be something
completely different and infinitely
worse
and so there's no turn like that there's
no surprise like that at being a house
of the dragon um
you know but that said like yeah no i
like this restaurant and i like the food
they make so i will keep
dining here until they make a shitty
version of this dish which
is possible because we were all here for
a house for for game of thrones the the
last bush
where it's like this is fine i guess i
suppose i've just been eating this pasta
quite a bit and if you can't even juice
it up a little with something surprising
i guess
fine
so yes
is it got a dragon in it it's got like
14 dragons in it you got a house in it
yeah lots of houses i think truth and
advertising that's all that matters get
what you paid for houses and dragons
man has joined us what do you have to
say for yourself i'll give my quick
review of the first episode
uh you also watched it i did watch the
good is you get dragons right up front
you don't have to wait for any dragons
you don't have to wait for them to be
little and grow up and
there's dragons right up front the
part that i
missed from the even the pilot of game
of thrones was
every almost every character is a
targaryen so they're all
there's not a lot of like
it feels tiny
because you don't have the
lannisters and the baratheons and the
starks and all these different
people playing this
political game you have like well we're
in charge and we're
the best and
like the stakes just seem so much
lower and
less interesting
um yeah and word the world is i think
you're right it's smaller because
like
we spend almost all of it in king's
landing
you know and while they do like they
were very careful to mention like that's
you know whatever the
african uncle was 500 years ago or 150
years ago like they're giving you those
little names
of you know
there's a tyrell night and there's that
person here's the high towers and you
know they're trying to conjure for you
the sense of expansiveness but it's very
small and so you never get that feeling
of right here's king's landing and we're
gonna go to winterfell we're gonna go to
that place like it's
it's very it's very chambered
that way um and yeah there's a lot of
blonde people and after a while
that many blonde people
um you know just freaked me out a little
bit
bobby jackson and chat said i think it's
supposed to be like succession for the
targaryens
would you does that seem
like the show you watched i mean i i
guess so yeah i mean it's a lot of
infighting but then again kind of so was
game of thrones
um to a certain degree and then it was
all about you know power and jockey for
position and betrayal and
and uh and chicaner and back stabbing
and all that stuff so
and that's a fair comparison but it's
not a new one
i am going to name drop mark but before
i do that i'm going to give credit where
credit's to again in chat they're
playing this game where they just keep
making
clerks on a plane slc clerks gangs of
new clerks a clerk called wanda
uh harry potter and the sorcerer's clerk
but the best one and this is only going
to be appreciated by somebody our age
was clerks 182.
wow zimmerman knew somebody's color blue
tyler blue is everybody knew
um
i uh here's my name droppy thing uh
recently uh i i don't i don't know if
you know this or not but i bought a
movie theater mark yes i heard so uh
we're in the process of closing and
mid-september it should be fully ours
it'll become smart castle cinemas uh
it's the atlantic movie house in
atlantic islands new jersey my childhood
theater um that all being said
once that story got out into the world
um a fellow movie theater owner reached
out to me uh a young upstart
fantasy novelist by the name of george
r.r martin who i met years ago
at uh the new chatel film festival uh in
switzerland going back a couple years
and stuff uh lovely man and i've spoke
about him i don't know if it was here or
if i've spoken about him on fatman
beyond but uh or on a
babylon or not
but such a geek like a hardcore fan and
one of the first
fans like when we met he was talking
about like um
he's going well if you ever pick up
issue three of the avengers and i was
like yeah if i'm rich one day
um he goes look in the letters column
and you'll see a letter from a young
george r.r martin
to you know uh
who is editing the book i guess stan
yeah probably to give him props for like
the uh mature storytelling the direction
it was going or something i was like you
wrote a [ __ ] letter
to marvel and he goes yeah it's an
avengers three avengers two or three
so he's like i'll do you one better he's
like because my i was gonna try to
imitate his voice but i won't do the
voice um he was like because my letter
was in the
in in the you know letters to the editor
thing
somebody reached out to me because this
is 1916 [ __ ] five six whatever the
[ __ ]
who was like hey
i like the letter that you wrote
in avengers man and i you i see you live
here i live real nearby
you ever want to hang out and talk about
comic books and he's like and we did so
he's like i met a circle of people
based on that letter that i wrote into
marvel people who had seen my letter and
liked what i had to say and we were
like-minded individuals
he's like and then one day we decided
that we could get together and trade
comic books sell comic books to each
other
um and so there were like 12 15 of us
and we got this
basement and i was like are you [ __ ]
me are you telling me
you were at the first comic book show
and he was like yeah he was like this
dude [ __ ] laid the track of fandom
he's not just the guy who wrote game of
thrones and [ __ ]
he was he was there in the beginning
when all this [ __ ] began when we're like
ooh let's gush about [ __ ] that's unreal
and discuss seriously you know [ __ ]
fantasy characters
the dude was there in the beginning he
was one of the first people to go to to
the san diego comic con
like
just [ __ ] nuts so the dude's a part
of of fandom as well as a guy who
generates fandom with his own work as
well so uh he's lovely absolutely lovely
and he reached out to me like out of
nowhere
i hadn't heard from him in years but
because i bought a movie theater he's
like well congratulations fellow movie
theater owner i saw that but he was
chiefly reaching out because of the
remember the hbo max story where
uh killed uh strange adventures
right so you know we talked about here
on the show and a couple websites picked
up um my description of what the uh
bizarro story with perry white and jimmy
olsen was gonna be
he he literally [ __ ] texted me for
the first time in like five six years to
be like that sounded like a really cool
story i'm sorry to hear it's not gonna
happen oh
[ __ ] creator of game of thrones
was just like had enough time to be like
damn i would have liked to seen that
bizarro story man it's like this
[ __ ] could write 20 better
bizarro stories but like what my point
of the story is not to be like he felt
bad for me it's illustrative of what a
[ __ ] fanboy this kid is at heart
um so
we've been chit-chatting
back and forth i'm gonna try to bring
clerk three to his movie theater his
movie theater is called the um
the oh [ __ ] uh in albuquerque
yeah new mexico one the uh it's a true
not true foe the
the
somebody in chat will dump it in there
but it's a french filmmaker's name or
french writer's name
um
in any event you know it's like a
hundred seater or something like that
cocktail thank you to dan horstmann the
cocktail theater so hopefully by
november late november december we're
gonna bring clerks through the cocktail
because i'm doing that because then i'm
gonna bring that [ __ ] to my
movie theater man we're gonna show the
red wedding episode i'm gonna be like
explain yourself you [ __ ] sadistic
i'm a [ __ ]
uh but he was so sweet he was just like
i would love to come to your theater
he's going it's been three years since
i've been back home he's from our neck
of the woods
he's from back there and [ __ ]
so
um he told me that he just bought a
[ __ ] trains
for his town that like these trains are
coming through his town for the first
time in like 50 years
and one is called uh the wolf and the
other is called the dragon of course
[ __ ] living his best life dude
god bless him but this is i tell you all
this to tell you what i feel is like one
of the the charming story
three days before
house of the dragon uh premieres
george texts me and goes house of the
dragons
is premiering on
sunday on hbo blah blah could you tell
as many people as you know about this
oh
and i was i wrote back i was like
george
pretty sure
the follow-up series to game of thrones
one of the most watched programs in the
world
needs no help whatsoever from the likes
of me man but how charming he was so
invested he's like i hope people watch
this show
and it was apparently the largest debut
in hbo history what i should have done
was [ __ ] tweeted and then be like
there you go george i did it i did it
for you
you're welcome
well i look forward to watching that
yeah um dragon show give it to me give
it to you how are they on the on the
nudity and all that [ __ ]
as it ever was it really so it's i
thought maybe this time around they'd be
like we're gonna tame that [ __ ] down but
they're still like look at it touch it
lick it like that kind of [ __ ]
yeah
that was how jason muse like got me to
watch the show he was like
all they do is [ __ ] on this show he's
like you see so much nudity he goes you
see dicks
and i was like you see dicks no no
nobody shows dicks on television or
anything he goes oh dude you see a dick
a day he's going it's the
the game of [ __ ] and [ __ ] yeah it's
very much like you know when uh when
when the criticism of quentin tarantino
and his foot fetish
you know start to come down the pike and
he's like all right i hear you i get you
understand
here's once upon a time in hollywood i'm
gonna put [ __ ] feet on the glass
[ __ ]
you get a problem with annuity you
thought maybe it's a bit exploitative
here you go lots more yeah
um all right so house of the dragon
dragon or dragons uh house of the
dragons
plural singular
singular house of the dragon uh now on
hbo
uh and
hbo max until [ __ ] they pull that off
yeah
um
is that all the reviews that's all the
reviews let's get into the shoes though
because i want to i want to while we're
talking about hbo max i want to talk
about the batgirl funeral
yes uh mark bernardin is a news hound
ladies and gentlemen an old newshound a
retired newshound and [ __ ] he's like
those movies where somebody finds a
grizzled old cop and [ __ ] and comes out
of retirement to solve a crime mark is a
grizzled old newsman who's like i lost
faith in the news but every once in a
while he finds his faith and he brings
the news to us every week here's martin
with the news um
the
what what is the batgirl funeral details
real quick set it up um the bad girl
funeral details are um apparently um
even though hbo max has decided not to
uh release
batgirl and warner brothers discoveries
decide that nobody will ever get to see
it
um
apparently around the warner brothers
lot there are some secret screenings
that are beginning to pop up uh they're
said to be for people who worked on the
movie both cast and crew as well as
agents and managers and lawyers and then
some executives um this is in the
hollywood reporter piece um one source
would describe them as funeral
screenings held before the film is sent
off to an undisclosed afterlife with
footage locked away in a vault either
physical and digital
um
and this was also in conjunction with
the news that
the directors um had tried to get copies
of the movie just for themselves that's
what i was thinking about i've read a
story where they went to pull
some of their footage from the server
this will teach you a [ __ ] physical
media [ __ ]
um their editorial was up in a [ __ ]
cloud right yeah they had a full ass
movie and before they you know
[ __ ] went south
they went to retrieve a copy of the
movie that they worked on you know not
to like take it to a movie theater but
their own personal copy perhaps yeah and
warner brothers deleted everything from
the server apparently all the raw
footage i mean in order to get this tax
write-off that they seem so desperate to
get they're like it can't exist anywhere
but then there was this follow-up story
that they're having screenings on the
lot
what they're calling funeral screenings
for people who worked on it so they
could see their work before
it will never be seen again
yeah i mean you know part of this
question is you know whether or not
warner brothers is actually going to
like
take the unprecedented move of
destroying the footage
as a way to demonstrate to the irs that
there will never be any revenue from the
project
um thus they can be entitled to the full
value of that write down because
sometimes that write down is portioned
over time
as opposed to the immediate lump sum
um you know but some people are like
that seems incredibly foolhardy given
that there's you know a bunch of other
projects that are first locked away that
will never see the light of day
including the first hbo spin-off pilot
um that apparently even george r martin
has never seen it's called blood moon i
think
um they shot a whole episode of a show
that was going to be a spin-off that
never happened but they just put in a
vault and moved on to house of the
dragon
wow
um
so like must be that must be nice to be
rich
you know to just drop
tens of millions of dollars into a hole
what's that line from bonzo goes to
bitburg maybe you got too much cash
um
but yeah so so yeah apparently like if
you know the right people or worked on
batgirl like you can see the movie
for a very very limited time and in a
very raw and incomplete form before
nobody ever gets to see it again unless
at some point in time
you know maybe there's a different
regime at warner brothers you know
coming down the pipe that says you know
what
maybe we should take a look at this and
see about you know finding a place for
it in the world um
they can always pay back the tax credit
if they want to whatever they got from
the write down they can return to the
irs and then pull the movie out of the
abyss
they wanted to
unless they could destroy the footage
in which days they can
sounds like
they still got trouble
over there in
burbank city with capital t and that
rhymes with wb that stands for
warner brothers
yeah warner brothers discovering
you know with the capital that runs the
wbd and that stands for warner brothers
discovery it does um they've had a not
great week over the warner brothers
discovery
um
earlier this week it was uh revealed
announced
you know spilled slipped snuck the
knowledge that batman the kid crusader
which 15 months ago received a series
order from hbo max and cartoon network
is among six animated projects that are
no longer being produced for hbo max
this was the cartoon that bruce tim was
working on uh that matt reeves was
working on jj was working on and mark
bernardin was working on am i correct i
was indeed i wrote an episode of batman
kate crusader um for ed brubaker and um
and bruised him
so wait a second though strange
adventures got killed my show got killed
your show got killed i think we're
getting to the heart of this oslob thing
man of this show at all
he doesn't like us much
the the the slight shade about this show
is that
um warner brothers animation is still
producing they're still going to make a
batman cartoon um
and they're going to sell it they're
going to
like take it to market and
somehow
for the first time in what feels like
50 years
there will be a batman thing in the
world that does not have a dc logo on it
or a warner brothers logo
why wouldn't it have a dc logo on it i
mean i mean you know it's not it's not
going to be on warner brothers air it's
not right yeah it's not one of it we're
going to make a batman thing and let it
go to somebody else right which
technically is what they did with batman
the animated series because it
originally aired on fox right when it
first ran and stuff but this is
something that the last
10 years in the age of the rise of the
streamer
everybody started taking everything
in-house
studios no longer produce content and
sell it to other competing studios or
networks because now every studio
presumably has its own streaming network
so
the whole idea for the last what feels
like decade has been
produce it and keep it in-house
for use for us uh but now
this would mean that for the first time
in a long time
they'd be producing something and
letting it go now some people be like
what about sandman how'd that go
that's different they
you know neil always kind of owned that
himself wasn't in that he owns i mean
there was a contractual like you know
this was in the rolling stone piece as
well um
like for the very first year of sandman
he had a standard work for hire contract
you know where none of it belonged to
him it was all you know dc and then in
success
he then went back to at the time paul
levitz and renegotiated his contract
which said that you know while he
doesn't own it
he is he is still the sort of controller
godfather of and he can sort of
determine and or veto things that happen
with sam
um
but you know batman
and also to be fair gotham was a batman
spin-off that went to fox any worth
about alfred went to epics you know and
those were times that hbo existed that
the cw existed that those things could
have gone
over there but it's hard to imagine a
thing that has the word batman in it
not being of interest to the parent
company on their
either cartoon network or hbo max
or hbo or cw which they're going to own
less and less of his time goes on but
it's just odd to me oh banff man's here
to save us from ourselves what's up
batman if you're kevin feige in disney
hold on one second hold on hold on
you can't just roll past that let's all
stop
and imagine if we were one of the most
talented [ __ ] storytellers
who has ever walked this planet
there is you know jesus who also told
great
stories then a bunch of [ __ ] happened
that is known for it was born
jesus that guy great stories nothing
else
um all right so i'm imagining i'm kevin
feige so this batman cartoon's going out
to the world and you're like
[ __ ] it
you buy it and you put it on disney plus
next to all the marvel stuff and you're
like this is ours now
smart plan man like why not yeah just
like really
yeah really own dc
like the number one cartoon of all time
on disney plus is batman
yeah the like you know how marvel owns
dc by literally owning dc
which i you know
look
i
i hope uh i i
i saw i i hope soon
that somebody is going to be put in
charge of all these amazing legacy
characters
and there's a plan going forward i
remember when they did their meeting or
their their shareholders call they said
that there'd be a
a kevin feige they were looking for a
kevin foggy they ever find that kevin
foggy mark uh they did apparently today
about half an hour before we went on the
air
yeah like very sure it was it was late
breaking news
all i can say is i'm flattered
uh but i can't take the job i'm sorry i
uh i have other things i'm going on the
clerk's three uh convenience tour so i
can't run
dc i can't beat kevin feige for dc mark
please pass on my regrets
you you know
you would like to serve at the pleasure
of the president alas your uh
your dance card is full uh no
they found their new dc sort of god head
he's a producer named dan ring
dan lynn has been in the business for
what feels like 20 25 years he's
produced movies um such as aladdin the
lego movie wait aladdin
the li the live action live action
elections
um how old is this guy
yes 78 years old
um you know he had previously worked for
alan horn when he ran warner brothers as
a president
um in the in the aunts
you know he had had a hand in making the
departed in 10 000 bc
and he oversaw the infamous and aborted
justice league movie that george miller
was going to direct with army hammer
batman yes cannibal batman i'm pretty
sure
indeed
uh it is liver with a fava beast in a
nice community
allegedly allegedly um he's worked on
the robert denny jr sherlock holmes
movies
um he did uh again aladdin
and he just did the uh the jokoy comedy
easter sunday
which came out in august
somehow preposterously far from sunday
um
from easter
and so and he's now going to be the guy
he's going to be the one that everything
dc feeds up to so all of the movie stuff
feeds up to him
all the tv stuff will feed up to him and
he will report directly to david says
love
uh well congratulations to dan lynn man
uh congratulations to him and my god at
the same time
good luck to you my friend because
yeah the the world is watching
uh and the internet is watching even
more closely and once
the world is far more forgiving than the
[ __ ] internet man like
i i honestly like believe me nobody was
ever looking at me for this job but
if if i was even on the list and
somebody called me i'd be like
it's tempting and as much as like oh my
god you can
pick which movies get to get made and
kind of put forward characters into the
culture that others don't know about
but
the amount of [ __ ] you're gonna have to
eat
with every decision you make like before
it comes out no matter what you do you
make a bunch of people happy and you
make a bunch of people unhappy and the
unhappy people are going to loudly tell
about tell you about it every damn day
online
if i'm dan lynn i'm getting rid of my
social media accounts right now yeah
just nuke the site for more of it man
just go into a bunker
because
it's like is his wife's like what about
all our family pictures it's like
doesn't matter man like no
we're going to batgirl that [ __ ] just
drop it in a digital well
bad girl
but yeah like
comparing him to kevin feige is not
doing him any favors either because it
really is i mean it's a shorthand so
that you know people could be like oh i
know what that guy does
so
you know i could make the correlation
but at the same time
yeah kevin feige wasn't kevin foggy
for like five years wasn't until they
were a string of those movies together
that people could be like hey there's
one name keeps popping up and he seems a
lot about these movies yeah like it
really wasn't like
it was the x-men stuff that helped it
was you know the hulk movie that sort of
moved him up and then it was
it was [ __ ] it was iron man
but even after even after iron man like
i would guarantee you most people
wouldn't be like oh kevin feig kevin it
wasn't until probably you get to
avengers
where like the average joe is just like
oh there's kevin feige he's responsible
for all these movies getting together
and he's he's the over brain or whatever
the [ __ ]
yeah like i think it's probably
it's it's probably captain america like
first avenger
when it's like okay we've done an iron
man we did a thor okay i get it i see
what's happening we're connecting these
things and even iron man 2.
but like once you get to captain america
and then you have the feeling that oh
you know well all these characters will
return in the avengers
it's oh [ __ ] we're doing a thing and the
avengers makes a billion dollars then
it's oh [ __ ] we've done a thing and
we're not done yet stay tuned we've got
15 more movies coming down the bike
we've got phases that we're doing like
all of that becomes clear tell you
something that was the greatest day one
of the greatest days of my life and i
wasn't even involved in that
but the day they were like we should
keep going that was the day that i
became alive mark and mind you i'd had a
wife and a child by then so yeah i know
what i'm saying
you know and also like to compare the
two is that you know kevin feige showed
up at a at a vacant lot
and got to build what he wanted to build
on yeah you know i'd like full cloth
it's all custom built you know there was
nothing he needed to tear down there was
i mean he had to wait for some deals to
expire to get certain characters here
and there but he got to
you know build the house he wanted to
build and the way he wanted to build it
and dan lynn is inheriting
you know a weird-ass lock that's got
like 19 different hands on it the walls
sometimes don't meet and there's
characters that they would like to use
but can't and there's
you know coats of paint that are uneven
like it's
it's not to say it's a complete tear
down but you're probably gonna have to
break it so you can fix it right it's a
bone that had been mended wrong it's a
an unenviable task
we gotta reward that guy huge for the
amount of [ __ ] he's about to take yeah
you know and i guess the last hbo max
story we will tell
this go-round is i think it's one of my
favorites
in that
hbo max has been pulling things off of
their servers you know sometimes their
movies sometimes their whole animated
series
and they've apparently pulled like
hundreds of episodes of the sesame
street
off of their service um the the the
reasoning behind it seems to be
that they have to pay like those things
aren't free like this doesn't exist in
purple duty but nothing even though your
producer to have it on your service to
air an episode of television
lots of people need to get paid you know
in perpetuity there's residuals that
need to get paid out for actors and
writers and performers and those things
cost
um not as much as producing a new
episode but it's not negligible either
and so rather than pay out those
residuals they decided to remove those
things
from the air
um
but uh the the sesame people they've
decided it's like you know what these
episodes are not going to be on hbo max
we're putting them on [ __ ] youtube
like
we are not going to be party to keeping
children and sesame street apart and so
we'll just put them up for free good
luck go for it enjoy
peoples
which i do love
the
fact that no one is safe anymore mark
yeah
not even
big bird
not even not even hurt gotta we gotta
watch his back
and they're coming for you bird
um
yeah man they uh
i don't know what's going on over there
i mean there's another story a business
story that uh the market cap which means
the valuation of the stock
has plummeted you know i think it had
been at the the close of the deal of the
merger at some 49 point whatever billion
dollars is what the company is valued at
and it dropped a good 20 billion over
the course of the last month
based in great part on the public
perception of these decisions
that that all of this in an effort to
cut three billion from the operating
budget or to reduce three billion from
their debt
um they've incurred a 20 billion
evaluation of stock
tila princess of parrots in uh chat says
was this week's story about wb not
having a budget to promote and
distribute films true
i didn't hear that story
you mean either i mean they still have
money they're operating in debt but
every company operates in debt
so if they decide they want to put out a
you know
whatever the [ __ ] harry potter movie
then they can promote it and distribute
it as they see fit um they've pushed
back the release dates of a bunch of
things including black adam and shazam
um oh i think black adam's still coming
out shazam and aquaman ii
um are getting pushed a bit deeper into
2023 yeah i saw their move being moved
as well yeah
so
i don't know what that's about but uh it
it seems to be a somewhat
um
fractured landscape
jc
they're saying in chat that your mic is
on they can hear you typing or something
so [ __ ]
um
the ant-man was furiously masturbating
during the show we [ __ ] caught him in
a jeffrey toobin type situation
i'm gonna glitter the walls
take it white oh megan white man
um
well that's the disney part of the news
we got another i'm sorry the warner
brothers part of the news we got some
other things such as quick hit uh
jeffrey dean morgan is joining the boys
for season four
oh absolutely yeah
nobody knows yet the knee is being kept
secret that would be intense
boys is like watch us make it work here
we go
man that show is [ __ ] good i i don't
doubt that they could pull it off
absolutely uh he's wonderful and such a
nice guy in real life i've interviewed
him once or twice for the imdb and
loving it lovely guy and then the
opposite of negan a real actor because
like he's not the [ __ ] prick he's
plays on tv
who i know is now an anti-prick i'm sure
it's gotta be yeah there's no way they
keep him around that long and he's still
the guy that [ __ ] bashed people's
heads in
yeah i mean the last like three or four
seasons have been the sort of negligent
reclamation project i think so like
started as a villain gets humbled tries
to earn his way back and
you know on tenuous alliances and maggie
still doesn't like him because you know
good reason
um yeah
yeah
i don't see her coming back from that um
but yeah can't wait to see what that
turns out to be um disney plus is an
early development dad he's [ __ ]
batman's dad man he is he is indeed
from the zack snyder verse
the angry batman dad i remember that
shot too because it's like he
he puts her his hand in front of his
wife and kid but then you see him ball
his [ __ ] fist up
which i thought was an interesting
approach that's something you know think
about the nolan incarnation um of of
thomas wayne you know he's a doctor he's
not the guy who's like
gonna give back but the
to have
what i liked about the snyder
interpretation was something i never
thought about before of thomas wayne was
wouldn't he have to be a bit knee-jerk
in order to have a kid
who then spends the rest of his life
beating the [ __ ] out of people who are
you know what i'm saying like
that one moment where they [ __ ] show
thomas wayne get like gritty and they
show his bald fist
is it like
the kid is the chip off the old block
like that's what [ __ ] batman
literally does every night and stuff
there's something i never thought about
when they did that i was like oh that's
[ __ ] dope man that's a that's an
interesting approach to the character
usually thomas wayne portrayed as
not weak but like not [ __ ] like i'm
gonna give as good as i get you know
right he's a victim yeah you know
whereas this version of thomas wayne
is not a victim
you know he just he gets beat you know
and he loses but he's not just he's not
just taking it right he's trying to
which then stands to reason that he's
got it's in the kid's dna
so he grows up to be a guy who's like
i'm going to put on this outfit and beat
the [ __ ] out of people yeah i mean i
either version of them still gets you to
a batman you know which is like i saw my
dad do nothing as a gunman shot him and
my mother i resolved never to be that
weak you know i i there's there's a
self-loathing there there's a like never
forgave his dad like i see how that
becomes the engine for for a vigilante
just as i see oh i saw my dad try to
stop it and he failed but i'm gonna i'm
gonna succeed where my dad failed i'm
going to be the one to stop crime i'm
going to be want to ball up my fist and
protect the innocent like i think
that just got me like you grabbed my
heart like okay it takes so little with
me i'm like i want to subscribe to your
comic book mark this boy he needs our
help
does he have further adventures than
china
is he a rich orphan
because next is a mask i'm telling you
what i'm looking for
the crossover nobody's asking for except
me
batman and reacher
so that reacher can have a conversation
with batman and be like you could
accomplish the same amount of [ __ ]
without all this
like the
sure
open station
it's like i heard an old an old jazz pro
played here once so
duke ellington came through here once in
1943 and he cut one of his best albums
and i'm gonna go to that thrift show and
buy myself some giant [ __ ] shirt and
super long jeans and punch people in the
head and shoot them in the back for a
while is that cool with you batman he's
like i do what you do just cheaper yeah
cheaper and they don't get back up
i finished the job
arca
what a waste
um the uh did you hear a rumor story
that they're talking to james gunn about
justice league too
i did not hear that but you know
it wouldn't surprise me either
um
i'd be delighted too look i'd love to
see james gunn direct anything
uh but it i guess with you know
guardians being finished
he's got to do something
um he's played in the dc universe as
well as he's played in the moment very
successfully i can't wait for them to
[ __ ] bring back peacemaker man i'm
telling you that one moment from that
episode where
john cena's dancing around like [ __ ]
was shirtless or something like that
that house
yeah and it's tiny what it's a house of
pain like with the flashback like it's
some [ __ ] powerful [ __ ] like i still
i added that song to my [ __ ] spotify
playlist because that was such a
profoundly impactful scene i texted him
to be like that was like so [ __ ]
beautiful man like
an unexpected
yeah yeah i'd love to see what he would
do with [ __ ] more dc properties yeah
i mean it's it does feel as if
there's a season of change about to
happen at dc probably brought on by
their new hire dan
of like listen we can't keep having ben
affleck back as batman clearly we can't
do any more movies with the flash person
um
who knows how long we're gonna have you
know jason mama for aquaman like it's
probably time to just kind of clean that
slate and start new
and like build it up from the beginning
so it is the things we want it to be and
if we can you know try and connect these
things the way we should and whether
james gunn is a big part of that and
helping to
let's let's build a brand new justice
league who's going to be in it who's our
band who's our superman because i think
there's also a rumor that you know henry
cavill is across the street trying to
you know talk into marvel about stuff
because
why wouldn't he be across the street
talking to marvel about stuff you know
if you can wonder i wonder who it could
play
i don't know
i mean there's probably a captain
britain who's not peggy carter that
somebody could put on a shield of
there's an excalibur there there's a
reed richards as well
the buffest reed riches you've ever seen
um
yeah he is pretty damn buff
um
a couple more quick things uh disney
disney plus is an early development on a
king kong television show
um which would be produced by james wan
and his atomic monster label written by
the creator of paper girls stephanie
folsom wait wait wait wait wait wait
yeah yeah yeah
disney
disney
universe hasn't universal been doing
those monster movies
um the the the
it's an entangled web of rights
um legendary legendary's been making
those legendary warner brothers by
making the godzilla movies and including
kong skull island and then you know
godzilla versus kong but i think the
underlying rights
to
king kong
are kind of a little bit all over the
place and so
if you go back to the original book
that it was based on like i think that i
don't know if that's in the public
domain or not at this point
but i think yeah like
okay so disney is doing a king kong
thing disney plus will be doing a king
kong series
i mean okay look i love disney plus i
watch whatever they [ __ ] put in front
of me that andor [ __ ] looks amazing yeah
um
but uh i hadn't seen that coming i would
have assumed it was with legendary or
something like that uh i've been asking
in chat fred meyer's asked in chat did
you i see the trailer for the new fletch
i have not yet have you seen the flex
trailer with john i saw it this
afternoon and
um i i don't know how to feel about it
this is the one that's gonna be on like
uh
showtime or hulu or
somebody's got it's not theatrical right
um it's unclear i
think it might
but i don't know it's not netflix i mean
i figured it out no no no but i remember
it was i want to say like showtime
bought it or something like that
confess fletch i think is the name of it
one of the one of the books in the
series of fletch books by gregory
macdonald but i would say let's see it
was fletch
um
bletch and the widow bradley maybe maybe
confess fletch was the second book
um
i used to know my fletch series very
well
but uh i look forward to it i i think
he'd be an amazing flesh man he's closer
i mean i'm not taking anything away from
chubby chase he was a great fletch but
in the books
he's like this impossibly handsome guy
that everybody wants to [ __ ] and that's
john hamm to a [ __ ] t
yeah i mean i guess my memories of
fletcher are so ingrained like i've
never read the book so i have nothing to
go on but the chevy chase of it all
and it definitely doesn't feel as goofy
as the chevy chase movies right the
books never were the books were were
he was humorous
but and he also like you know [ __ ]
used uh
you know akas but like not like he the
movie thing was
him in all these different like outfits
or personas that was definitely more of
a movie trope
gotcha
um so yeah like i because i have so
little basin on i'm like oh okay this
looks like it could be a
totally charming detective story
um
but
myers is saying it's a dual release in
theaters and on vod so i was incorrect
it's not showtime it's both theatrical
and you can watch it
on demand on the day or whatever
makes sense
um so yeah i like look totally fine and
serviceable i'm just not a die-hard
fletch fan to have a deep big opinion
about it um so i do look forward to your
thoughts because i know you are
that person
i almost made a fletch movie years ago
maurice trump two for years with uh
jason lee as a young fletch there's a
book in the series called fletch one
w-o-n that gregory mcdonald wrote way
late in the series
that went back and told his secret
origin story of how fletch first got the
job on the paper
one of my favorite [ __ ] books of all
time still
to this day
um all right what else we got newswise
we got one little quick thing um uh john
boyega doing press
for his film breaking which i'd like to
see the trailers are really what is it
it's very dog day afternoon it's very or
like john q it's very much about a guy
who takes a bank hostage because he
needs to have his story told and this is
the only way to get the media's
attention you know i want to say that
he's a he's a vet who had gotten kind of
screwed over
um it's sort of a vet of the star wars
series who got screwed over a vet of the
star wars series who got screwed over
which
is very much his story
um and so we did an interview uh on
siriusxm with uh john fugelson talking
about um
his opinions his perspective on star
star wars at this point and i think one
of the questions was like hey man would
you come back would you come back and
play finn
you know let's let's pretend that they
decide they want to greenlight a fin
show is that a thing you'd want to be in
and he says you know at this point like
i'm cool not being in it like i just
he's like i think finn is at a point
where you can enjoy him and other things
in the game and the cartoons
but he thinks that you know i feel that
episodes
uh seven to nine was good for me
um
you know but he also says that like he
was at the forefront
of the kind of the toxic or the toxicity
of the fan base when he showed up to
play finn
that you know it's like it was it was
brutal for him and disney had no idea
how to deal with it because they didn't
know it was coming down the pike
um but he says that watching
how disney sort of rallied the troops
around moses ingram
you know he's like moses being protected
made me feel protected it's like it made
me feel like okay i'm not it's like when
i started wasn't even the conversation
you could bring up and you know how they
went through it let's just be silent it
wasn't a conversation you could have but
to see how blatant it is now the racism
and to see you and mcgregor come on
support
it fulfills his time in which he didn't
give any support
um
you know but for all of this he says
maybe when i'm 79 years old maybe you
know when they give me an offer to come
back and ride the millennium falcon he's
like maybe like harrison ford i'll be
like all right chewie i'm home
so cute little story this is a cute
story but underlining
sadness of like
you know
he didn't have a very good experience
with star wars no
no i think star wars for him was was
incredibly fraught because he like many
of us grew up loving it and you offer
him the chance to sign up for it
and it was a little bit of a bait and
switch it's like you know that the way
those movies should have worked is
like
it seems as if
you put these two characters on a movie
poster you know when you introduce them
young and then like they're going to
grow up together and like
finn had nothing to do with the rest of
those movies finland being from being
integral to window dressing
and you know i was never really written
two or written for and
you know it seems like that should have
been a romantic story that they were
never invested in making
um and then the abuse that got keeped on
him for being a black person in star
wars um
who looked like he might at some point
become a jedi
um was too much apparently and so it's
like you know what i'm fine i don't need
to i don't need to walk back in that uh
in that pool
hey
resident star wars fan and uh
noted space port bar owner
jc banff man himself what do you got to
say there i saw somebody in chat one
after your [ __ ] head shaving yeah
[ __ ] man
people don't like my hair
i think it's cool i think it's cool it
makes you look young
thank you it's also like
i don't know i have my own companies i
don't got to impress anybody except for
jen exactly
he can wear his hair like that as a true
son that he don't [ __ ] work for
nobody except himself that's a big win
right there i'm on box
um the tragedy of finn
is that
uh we've seen an
orphan from a desert planet become a
jedi before and we've seen
fighter pilots in star wars but we never
saw
a character that was an imperial turn
into
a rebel or whatever they call it in the
new movies but he was a a bad guy
whose heart was so good he couldn't do
it and he had to turn into a good guy
and that backstory is
the most original thing in
the force awakens
and then it wasn't
like i would have leaned the whole
sequel trilogy into that aspect yeah
talk about
talk about redemption you know like
[ __ ]
you're talking about a guy who starts
with the bad guys and works his whole
story arc to
be with the good guys to defeat the bad
guys you're right it was kind of like
they hadn't done that storyline in any
of the star wars movies before no
traitors no flippers right it could have
been
so cool
yeah and he comes to that realization on
his own
you know he doesn't need to really come
into or or into contact even with a jedi
to show him the right way or whatever it
is it's like no i knew it was bad and i
did the thing that none of the other
schmucks in my outfit would do is i left
you know and now i'm a wanted man
you know i think that's it's so
captivating it's so strong you know that
that you're right it's it's it's money
they left on a table it's story they
left untold which is a shame
um
is that the last of the stories it's
last the news my friend there it is kids
there's your [ __ ] news you wanted it
you got it bernardin
did i just open a hotel in the poconos
yes
um speaking of showing up uh what is
today thursday yeah
saturday and sunday meaning like not
tomorrow but the day after
i'm going to uh toronto mark for fan
expo canada
toronto as they say uh where i'll be uh
taking pictures with the uh clerk's cast
as well as my kid this is her first con
she's rule summer's harley quinn smith i
was like what about jane salam bob
reboots her heart yoga hosers harley
quinn smith she's like that's okay
full summer harley quinn
uh so i'm gonna be taking pictures with
her signing stuff me and jay do jane
salam bob get old on saturday night
uh sunday night
after the con because i'm there two days
uh we're doing a screening of clerk
at the scotiabank uh theater the
cineplex
and uh me and malcolm the director
malcolm not clerks three but clerk the
documentary in my life malcolm directed
he's from toronto uh we're having that
screening on sunday night come on out
and join us kids tickets at
ceasemod.com and then don't forget one
week after that one week from this
sunday the
convenience tour begins red bank new
jersey man uh follow me across the
country as i show people clerks and then
take a bunch of [ __ ] for it in person
after the movie at a q a uh clerks three
dot movie for tickets
and then in between all of that
we have the last cantina show
for a very long while that's right when
is that that's happening tuesday isn't
it that's the 30th of august i believe
if i know how calendars work so kids
this is your last chance for a while to
see us do uh west coast kids this is
your last chance or east coast if you
feel like getting on a plane and coming
to join us yeah we're not gonna stop you
um this is the last chance to see us uh
me and mark do it in front of you cuck
us out uh until i'm done with the
clerk's uh three the convenience store
yeah some of that [ __ ] really
make that eye contact with
tickets available right now probably at
csmount.com but definitely at the uh
eventbrite site wherever jc always puts
our tickets up for sale
come on out and join us kids before i
hit the road and
who knows man maybe i'll never come back
this could be the last chance to see fat
man be on live don't miss it get tickets
right now give us your money
and let us honor you
yeah
um all right uh next up of course we're
gonna do some q a kids
but before that we got another sponsor
ladies and gentlemen we don't do this
show
uh without somebody powering it fueling
it
and the tonight the second half of fat
man beyond is fueled
uh by uh
that which gives rise
to all challenges
mark um
it don't get harder than this kids
i would like to erect the case
for blue chew ladies and gentlemen
bluechew.com is where you want to go go
to
bluetooth.com right now
while we're talking and talking about
bluetooth uh because you could try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code fatman
at checkout just pay five dollars for
shipping you can get free free blue chew
for five bucks just for the shipping
cost you can try it out pop it in be
like we'll see and then you will see
it's like [ __ ] popeye man with the
spinach you pop the can but
no
that's how it works i i believe because
the animation that they showed us looks
exactly like that
that's bluechew.com kids with the promo
code fat man to receive your first month
absolutely free you don't get a better
deal than that visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
this podcast uh mark yeah
guys
uh confidence can take you far in life
uh it can also help you in the bedroom
especially when it comes time to step up
to the plate
what
i'm talking about you know what i'm
talking about i'm talking about little
more boy i'm talking about s-e-x
i'm raising arizona um i just rewatched
that what a brilliant movie that holds
up and [ __ ] do you can you remember any
other time that nick cage and holly
hunter have worked together
no
why not they were so [ __ ] good in
that movie
i'll do you one better
can you think of another time the coen
brothers worked with nick cage
no
what happened
like one of the greatest pairings of all
time that performance is [ __ ]
my name is h.i mcdonough like amazing
can't believe that like they only worked
with holly hunter one other time too i
think like on uh oh brother we're out
there i'm sorry i'm a big raising
arizona nerd i'm dying
we're here to talk about raising arizona
kids although we are talking about
raising [ __ ] because we're talking
too if you've named your penis arizona
let's talk about raising it absolutely
man um blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients
as viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets at an a fraction of the cost man
you could take them anytime
day or night man so you can plan ahead
or be ready whenever the opportunity
arises
kids and i i don't know if you've been
getting these implications but this is
me miming boners over and over again
yeah i went bigger
i went and went the full arm
did you so this is mine mine's like
thumb dick so just like that
pete fuhrman in chat wanted to know if i
used blue chew to get my hair to stick
up straight like that
i don't know
somebody else in chat said that the uh
what is the mohawk if not a middle
finger to the world and i was like yeah
yeah
the um
between bluechew and manscape
you can
look so big
right that's true man you can pop the
blue chews
and while you're waiting for him to kick
in you pull out your lawn mower and
[ __ ]
shave your [ __ ]
make it look even bigger yeah
good point man yeah making sure man came
in to be like here's a tip here's a life
hack to make your dick look bigger and
then he just left just like that yeah
like shave him clean or get a smaller
person to have sex with yeah
it's an optical illusion
forced perspective it's called
process is so simple kids sign up at
bluechew.com and consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and uh
once you're approved by god you're gonna
receive your prescription within [ __ ]
days man and the best part is it's all
done online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations where
you're like look i want a stronger boner
and he's like you could use better
[ __ ] terms than that
say you're wrecking
nudely yeah can you help me from feeling
nudely
blue chews tablets are made right here
in the good old us of a man where we
make all the good [ __ ]
[ __ ]
sorry i was invaded by a very large
house fly
[Laughter]
remember last show there was a [ __ ]
roach came out what is with this buggy
house i live in i'll tell you what it is
my wife has this [ __ ] fresh air
policy where she opens up every [ __ ]
window and [ __ ] and every living thing
yeah i'm talking about you every living
thing comes in and [ __ ] with me mark
i need to pop a few blue chew to take
all of these insects man
[Music]
you can reload your arms like [ __ ]
cattle and just get after it
uh blue chew man the tablets made right
here in the usa they come in discreet
packaging
blue chew is everything kids blue chew
is a religion join it pray to blue chew
um don't forget we've got a special deal
for our listeners try bluetooth free
free for nothing foc free charge when
they uh you use the promo code fat man
all one word at checkout all you're
gonna do is pay five dollars shipping
that's bluechew.com
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w dot com promo code
fatman to receive your first month free
crazy good deal visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information and we thank
the good folks at blue chew for
sponsoring this here podcast man get
your dick pills for no bills
look at that [ __ ] they need you i've
been thinking about that all day bernard
copy right there
um
let's see uh ladies and gentlemen now
that we've gotten uh the uh
you know uh
sponsorship i'm sorry i keep eyeballing
my [ __ ] dog shecky is out on the
porch and she's
marching back and forth and i don't know
why
you know every once while your dog does
something very uncharacteristic where
you're like
kind of transmission are you receiving
yeah it's like who told you to stand
guard
yeah really
all right [ __ ] jc man it's time to
hear from the audience
um
uh they get to ask us questions we get
to answer those questions
jc is going to facilitate providing with
us with those questions banff man makes
it happen
so uh here we go kids we're off to the
races we're at the q a part of this
long ass show we started what time four
like 15.
yeah 4 30 i think 4 30 so we're already
at the 2 hour and 15 minute mark so if
these answers are circumspect and short
forgive us
still 90 minutes shorter than the last
show
thank god for the internet this is like
this is where that's why like you know
[ __ ] such a good thing that sesame
street went to youtube man because
people got time on youtube yes keep on
rolling i saw a lot of people in chat
today who were like because we started
so early they're like i never get to see
this show
this is fun it's always cute when people
like i had no idea how much fun the show
is to watch because they normally just
listen to it or something
yeah watch us cuck it out look at me and
mark look at us look right here
all right well how come you don't get
close enough to the camera to do it you
won't commit
well because i got a microphone between
me and this and so suddenly i got to
start like climbing over [ __ ]
well that well that will show how
[ __ ] passionate you are mark yeah
that's how sexy it gets i gotta mount up
it did look kind of sexy when you were
calling folks yeah look at that [ __ ] the
top mounter
um all right
again
um
let's uh let's find out what they want
to know jc
uh igor
berezin wanted to know what is the most
not expected great movie in your life
meaning
when you watch a movie and you expect it
to be terrible but it's actually
fantastic
so i guess the what movie by surprise
yeah yeah i get i'm just trying to think
over a lifetime
i don't go into much going like this is
gonna suck like i go unhopeful for
everything where i'm like oh this
movie's gonna be amazing and then you
know [ __ ] again tricked um
i'm trying to think has there been
something where i was like this is gonna
be [ __ ] dumb and then i was like ooh
bamf mine
pirates of the caribbean i thought it
was going to be terrible oh excellent
all right you know what based on that i
do have one as well because i too was in
your camp when they announced pirates i
was like what why
and then you know it turned into a great
series uh i i will never forget uh
hearing about the lego movie
and being like
dumb
dumb
dumb oh my god who would watch this why
are they doing this are they so
desperate
for [ __ ] content that they're making
a lego move and
lego movie is one of my favorite movies
of all time it is it stole my heart it
was it's literally legit a brilliant
movie um the lord and miller man those
talented [ __ ] kids behind the spider
spider-man into the spider-verse talents
get
kids behind the solo movie we'll never
see speaking of [ __ ] you know batgirl
getting [ __ ] shelved and [ __ ]
disney's got some of those [ __ ] you
know there's a whole ass solo movie
which i would like to see
pull out of the vault the disney vault
that'd be amazing
um but yeah man i i that lego movie is
still magic to me i still get chills
thinking about it
the crackle
craggle that was it um yeah [ __ ] such
a good movie uh what about you mark you
got one
i'm trying to think of one that i
thought was going to be bad
as opposed to one that i had no opinion
of whatsoever
you know and and i think that was
for me the most recent one was coda
um where like i walked it somewhat out
of obligation and i was like well it's a
[ __ ] oscar-nominated movie so i
should probably watch it before the
oscars and just see what it's all about
and it's on streaming so i don't have to
you know put in some code and watch a
screen or go out to them well i it was
the easiest one to watch so i watched it
it had zero expectations of it
and then found myself just bawling like
an idiot by the end of it
um
to the point where i'm not sure i can
watch it again because it was just that
emotional experience like it's been a
long time since i cried
that uncontrollably in a movie
um
and i think there was there was uh what
you got to face in chat jason brown just
said dan lynn produced the lego films
i said that you did say that now i'm
putting it together [ __ ]
the d there's hope for this dc universe
mark he's got some skills yeah those
lego movies are [ __ ] wonderful
i will also say that i i had zero
expectations for a movie called
mitchell's the mitchells versus the
machines
um also a lord and miller also lord
miller jam like i you know the trailers
didn't quite captivate me but i was i
was ironically enough
on a college visit with my son and we
were in the hotel room like before we
went to sleep and he was like well [ __ ]
it let's flip through netflix and like
whatever
it looks cute enough
and it just so happened to be a story
about a family moving their kid into
college as i'm at a college student with
my kid and it's wonderful and it's
moving and it's you know it'll roll or
tear or two
um
it's so great it's i mean i i rarely
roll into movies that i think are going
to be bad
but i often roll it because i don't i
try not to have any preconceived
expectations for things
um but i do go over there we'll see what
this is and then
you know the the pleasant surprise of
coming across a new favorite movie that
you didn't think was going to happen is
fantastic so i go with those two hoda
and mitchell's versus machines that's a
great question man produced some great
results all right
next up there jc jason
next one is from a guy named i shouldn't
say a guy is from a person named false
flags
uh who says speaking of silence of the
lambs q lazarus who wrote goodbye horses
died this week
what are some songs from movies that
have affected kevin and mark
um that's absolutely true uh we did lose
q lazarus and uh that song uh is
uh goodbye horses is so incredibly
meaningful to pop culture
mostly everybody knows it from
silence of the lambs we ripped it for
clerks too when jay did his silence of
the lamb's dance um
uh apparently he uh jonathan demi
i wouldn't say discovered q lazarus but
met q lazarus in a
cab or something like that was being
driven someplace and
listening to
music and and he was like who is this
and q lazarus was like it's it's me
so he used uh jonathan demi the late
great jonathan deming used uh goodbye
horses first i think and married to the
mob if i remember correctly
and but then you know just as a track it
wasn't prominent but then it captured
the world's imagination because that was
the
that's the song that accompanies the
infamous tuck
the first time in mainstream cinematic
history where
somebody [ __ ] tucked their dick back
and [ __ ] and you know this was the
late 80s early 90s i'm going to say the
early 90s was it 91 that silence came
out or 92.
um there was no internet yet kids now
you know people can't if you're young
you can't appreciate the impact of that
cinematic tuck
so much so that like it
it burned that song
into everybody's imagination who saw
that movie because
yeah shecky chucky knows
that song is forever tied to the image
of like that you know [ __ ]
james gum doing this [ __ ] and then
[ __ ] like doing this and then
going back and doing this and you see
that he's tucked his dick back just
mind-bending moment in cinema history at
that point now you know you can see it
on tick-tock i'm sure
not that one everybody doing
it's a thing
um wow man so yeah so your song the song
that means is it that one or did you
have another video to talk about
what is this and it's a movie song right
um
yeah i mean there yeah i got one i i got
what i mean it's gonna be self-serving
because it has to do with clerks three
coming in theaters very very soon
september 13th to the 18th of fathom
events theaters participating theaters
or see with me
on the convenience tour starting
september 4th running through till
december
all across this great land of ours uh
also i heard for those good folks in the
uk
uh september 13th 16th in that area it's
coming out there unfortunately i'm not
going to be able to go over there
because i'm touring through the states
and stuff but
they're not going to have to wait
overseas they're going to see clarks 3
pretty damn soon anyway
there is a song in clerks three that
closes out clerks three
and i'm gonna keep saying clerks three
so it subliminally sticks in everybody's
head and makes them buy a ticket to
clerks three clerks
clerics three um
the uh the song uh that ends clerks
three is a song by john gorka that i've
been trying to get into a movie forever
and it's a song called i'm from new
jersey
and it is
i remember the first time i heard it was
in another movie it was the closing
credits track
of a film that was shot in my neck of
the woods in new jersey called fathers
and sons that starred jeff goldblum and
rory cochran
and i watched the movie when we got it
at rst video because i was like oh they
shot that in highlands
and uh you know when when the movie
ended this very melancholy john gorka
song kicks in
um that has one of my favorite lyrics
ever written where he says i'm from new
jersey it's like ohio but even more so
imagine that
you know
pretty profound if you're from the state
so i i fell in love with it in
in that movie fathers and sons and like
always tried to i tried to use it in
jersey girl
um
and then it wasn't like we weren't
allowed to it would just eventually fall
out of the cut or somebody had some
other song
um but uh clerks three
ends with uh the john gorka song uh i'm
from new jersey and
that's an imp that's a powerful song i
think i first heard that tune on that
movie in 91 92
when it came out
and it was such a great [ __ ] song
that made such a deep impact
that
you know what 30 years later or more
i i'm using it to close out like the
most
biographical film i've ever made to date
the most personal movie i've ever made
to date
um and using the anthem
the melancholy anthem i'm from new
jersey by john corker so yeah that's
that i would say that song made an
impact that's a movie song that made a
deep impact in me
you um
my my knee-jerk reaction
was
um
a tiny dancer
from
from almost famous right beautiful
moment it's beautiful moment you know
and that that movie means a lot to me
in
in
like i first saw that movie when i was a
young entertainment journalist not
nearly as young
as uh as as as
young young william young william miller
um is in that movie but you know still
relatively new into into the business
and that feeling of being a little bit
under
water and not knowing you know if you're
up to the task and you do have some
talent but you're not sure if you can do
the job and like
trying to find out where home is for you
and what it means like all of that stuff
and then that song is this
wonderful crystallization of community
um and so i do have such a soft spot in
my heart for that movie and i do love
that moment
but there's another movie that meant
quite a bit to me in the 80s
because it's so [ __ ] it's it's the
kind of 80s movie you see and we're not
sure you could feel as bad as humanly
possible after watching it um
but the movie is the last american
version virgin
which
is this
devastatingly cratering movie about
young love that goes awry
which which the way you've described it
is poetic
but this is
sold as conceived as
and portrayed as
the titiest
teen titty movie of all time it was like
uh it was based on an israeli series of
films called lollipop i believe and the
same filmmakers made the america the
last american version they just made an
americanized version of that movie and
you know like most 80s teen movies it's
boys who are very preoccupied with sex
but this took like porkies and amped
everything up they saw porkies and they
were like oh that's what you're allowed
to do all right [ __ ] it this is what
we're going to do
so
whenever you watch this movie
the first
hour
plays like the most
pure aisle [ __ ]
you know boys want to get
nookie movies you've ever seen
and then in the last half hour
becomes a completely different movie
that is reliant on the first hour
but
becomes a different emotional experience
i need to know what song it that it is
that you're talking about
it's you know and again to set it up and
we're going to spoil it 40 year old
movie at this point but it's you know
this guy is you know it's the [ __ ]
teen in high school and his best friend
always gets the girls and he doesn't but
he's got to get his eye on this like
exchange student or whatever i think
it's gene exchange i might be mixing
that up with better off dead because
it's the same actress as diane franklin
it is a stein franklin who was also an
amityville ii
yeah she had a big remnant in that time
but he had the biggest question also one
of the princesses in bill and ted
that's right
she was an 80s princess if ever there
was one and uh and so
he loves carries the biggest torch for
this girl um they're like super close
friends but then she ends up going off
with his friend who i want to say his
name is boner because it sounds like it
would be his name in the movie um i
don't think it's boner but i think it's
like a guy who would play boner in
another movie um he is a guy the guy who
played him as an actor named steve anton
who went on to write and i think direct
ins no right
inside monkey zetterland remember that
movie from like yeah
90s or something wow yeah anyway she
goes off she has sex with this guy his
best friend you know who he is i'm sorry
here's a shorthand that guy is the same
actor who's like andy you gooney that's
that same [ __ ] dude right that's
steve
um
and so she goes off has sex with his
best friend the guy who's always with
about the ladies gets pregnant
the best friend like leaves flat leaves
her [ __ ] off he doesn't want to deal
with her responsibility our hero schlub
then takes this girl to get an abortion
and cares for her and like nurses her
back to health and thinks that it's the
thing and then he goes to some party
thinking it's gonna be the moment where
she
you know not to say rewards him
but like
he's gonna give her a ring
he's gonna propose to her like it's the
whole [ __ ] thing and then he sees her
kissing the same dude who got her
pregnant and leaves her behind and so
the last shot in this movie is this guy
getting in his car
probably driving off to shoot himself in
the mouth
and tommy
i never thought of that it's possible
it's impossible because if a person has
ever been as emotionally devastated as
that guy i've never seen another one and
so he's driving along his car and then
tommy two-tones like teen angel eyes
comes on the [ __ ] stereo and it's the
saddest thing you've ever [ __ ] seen
and
what is wait what is your memory what
song is it
i'm pretty sure that it's tommy two-tone
teen angel eyes he's like that song i'll
bet i'll i'll put hard money big money
folding paper money
yeah open arms by
journey no
no
i know exactly what one it is because it
haunts me and i've had this song
on playlists either on cassette
or on a mixtape made for girlfriends or
on my uh cd collection and of course now
on spotify you ready for it
i did my best but i guess my best wasn't
good enough
cause lord knows we're not
kicks in and you're like
oh my god like this movie which has all
been all about like we all try to [ __ ] a
hooker and get crabs and [ __ ] like that
like good old good times dirty good
times let's measure our dicks with
rulers and [ __ ] like that ends with this
emotionally devastating [ __ ] gut
punch where this guy is driving haunted
and this [ __ ] song
which is the last song in the world you
ever imagined would end a teen titty
comedy it is like one of the most
melancholy meditative songs since uh i'm
from new jersey
it's this this guy incongruently driving
a teenager listening to this like
devastating song about like a broken
marriage or some such [ __ ]
um it is it it's [ __ ] that's the is
that the moment that's the song that's
the moment that's the song because i
think yeah the tummy t-tone comes after
them comes right afterwards because as
the credits roll in then they play like
an upbeat song
that's so [ __ ] up man but yeah
that moment
haunts me to this day i haven't seen the
movie in 20 years maybe more
but like
that that defined what i thought teenage
love was going to be
like awful and the worst and you know it
did prove out to be kind of prophetic
because
i did not have a great love life in my
teens and like my big high school
girlfriend kind of [ __ ] me over and so
oh really yeah well wait a second wait a
second did you try your best and you
your best just wasn't good enough
apparently
because lord knows you're not getting
anywhere no
um but yes you're the guy you're the guy
that's driving around [ __ ]
oh absolutely just once yeah figure out
what we keep doing wrong
you know like trying to set my gps for a
cliff to drive off of
before gps existed that's how [ __ ]
head of the curve he was where's
asking the movie phone guy to lead me to
a cliff in in uh the chat dixon cider
said last american virgin is one of the
classic cuck in cell movies i've never
heard that before
we didn't have a word for it we were
just sad boys yeah and it was but it was
like honestly a cautionary tale and a
horrifying movie because it did make you
think like
who can you trust
like you can't trust your girlfriend she
she turned around and [ __ ] his friend
over it you know in retrospect it is
kind of a
[ __ ] incel movie isn't it man
i mean i i just i
it was the like
crystallization
of the theory which i don't think is
proven out over the course of my life
but
there's nothing good about being a nice
guy
yeah you know and and you know i have
since learned differently but at like
whatever 17 or 16 years old when you see
that movie and you're raw and you're
just wet clay it's like oh [ __ ] man
these brunches don't do it you did it
man you tried to be a good dude and you
just got [ __ ] burned by it
and so you got mad at an entire gender
yeah like which is
not healthy for anyone
people are a lot of people in chat are
like i need to see this movie
if you go we're on youtube if you open
up another screen and enter
last american virgin ending
i guarantee you somebody has clipped it
if not multiple people because
it apparently affected an entire
generation of teenage boys oh yeah
oh yeah
like i would say we should find a way to
screen you know share the screen and
just roll it into the [ __ ] podcast
except we would get booted off we would
absolutely totally like maybe we do it
as the closing credits of the podcast so
that if they close the feed
yes
i got a [ __ ] good good ass idea
though when we open this movie theater
and [ __ ] and you know we'll be doing
like fat man beyond shows back there
like live in person
you can also do a fat man beyond
screening series and we totally like the
screening series of fat man beyond would
include last american virgin
streets of fire
[Music]
right think about all the movies that we
deeply love and have talked about on the
show and stuff like that what else david
lynch's dune dune
lynch and dune excellent
we need we need two more at least uh
part of me really wants to see if you
can find like mega force
deeds not words yeah [ __ ] ace hunter
oh my god the great hal needham
um
yeah one one more to make the the
quintet to like bookend a weekend
fat man film festival dan horstmann and
chat says i will drive up for dune
yeah you will
um
all right uh one more question yeah i
think we got another question what about
you
i've got
one that's really
strange and will show my age a little
bit um
when uh
i was like 10 or 11
when robin hood prince of thieves came
out
and when everything i do i do it for you
plays at the end of that movie
i it was the exact opposite of
your guy's experience where i was like
this song and these lyrics have got to
mean
what love is like this is it like brian
adams somehow
bottled love and put it into the notes
of this song like it it
made me feel things at 11 that i didn't
know i could feel and then years later
in 2018 2019
when jen and i were talking about our
wedding she's like
i just i really want a wedding that
feels like the end of robin hood prince
of thieves like in a forest with
petals falling so it got hurt too
so that's the song that means a lot to
me because it's so
cheesy but like at that age i just was
like oh i get it now i really get it now
i'm i'm i'm with you man i remember the
power of that song he's also he's a good
movie song guy because remember he also
did uh
um
uh when you love a woman
tell her that she's really wanted from
dom juan demarco oh my god and then he
also did the three musketeers uh song
with sting and somebody else right like
oh
yeah man that brian [ __ ] brian adams
songs cut like a knife [ __ ]
thank you
um all right [ __ ] enough blowing
brian adams um although when i think him
and the other the movie song that
instantly comes to mind for me is
um real genius
when um they do the laser thing across
campus and he follows the big party
um they play one night love affair is
playing when when uh the the
the guy
the
guy who's having
the kid build the [ __ ]
laser mirror or whatever [ __ ] when he
comes to right now hathaway dr noah
hathaway comes to say he's really
disappointed in mitch and [ __ ] um that
song's [ __ ] playing and he's all
bumped out [ __ ] one night love affair
um this is the brian adams podcast brian
appreciation podcast ladies and
gentlemen
all right we're talking about summer of
69. yeah yes
another episode of crying for brian
brian
ryan for brian
um what's our final question of the
evening bam bam uh z howard wants to
know
if you could make up an interesting
court case against a hero or villain in
the mcu
who would be involved and what would the
case be about so like
uh
you know
a few good men but marvel
i'm trying to look like one of those
yaks in uh it's a small world
a court case against a marvel hero and
or villain i mean villains are easy
um
[Music]
i don't know
i don't know enough about
things that are illegal
people know enough about the law
to be like well i'm pretty sure there's
a tort case against kingpin for
poor use of
right-of-way signs or some [ __ ]
um
i mean there's always property damage
you're gonna bring against the hulk
i'm
what is the question again i think i got
one
uh a uh interesting court case in the
mcu
it has to be mcu [ __ ] i was about to
enter the dcu
i mean
there's no reason
mark you go first okay i i would bring
i would have greenpeace i think
or somebody bring an environmental law
environmental suit
against the eternals
for leaving a gigantic half of a deviant
erupted in the ocean and then just
walking away
like the [ __ ] are we supposed to do with
this like
it's ruining all kinds of of natural
habitats i'm sure there are breeding
grounds for whales and fin sharks and
whatever that are now [ __ ] up because
there's half of the dead god here um and
then it's not a deviant a an eternal
sorry
what wait what was there what were their
big figures called
the celestials
that's in the ocean yes yeah with just
like a hand rising and half of a torso
and it's just [ __ ] there
and
you somebody's got a music who's gonna
foot the bill for us removing a giant
half a stone celestial and it seems as
if the eternals if they were smart would
have started a bank account in zero a.d
and the interest alone should have been
enough to pay for the removal of a half
a celestia
um yeah i think it's it's it's an
environmental suit
brought maybe by like the world health
organization or some [ __ ]
that's what i got
i like it
um
i mean i should be able to do it in
[ __ ] the marvel universe but i'm
gonna cheat and step outside and do it
in the dc universe because it has to be
a compelling legal case that i'm
interested in
and so
um
i think
it would be amazing
if
a low-level hood
doesn't have to be the joker
um
a low-level villain in batman's rogues
gallery
um file the lawsuit
against batman
for harassment and assault
um
you know or worse uh what is it called
when they [ __ ] punch in [ __ ]
battery battery
oh
battery
um and so that course that i mean like
batman's all about the law granted he
works outside the law but he's all about
justice and [ __ ] you know
first you gotta
get a [ __ ] subpoena to him or
whatever [ __ ] like
will he show up to court if he shows up
to court you can make him [ __ ] unmask
because you'd be like ladies and
gentlemen the jury he's lying he's a
liar a man in a mask sits in front of us
and we're expected to believe the truth
is coming out of his mouth
i say nay
that's the case i'd like to see
i i see i i really love this episode of
like law and order
you know because it's it's the serious
version of that snl bit where it's like
batman i hate that [ __ ] guy
think he beat up my cousin like he broke
my elbow like my cousin pinot's nose
don't work right anymore it's like oh
he's just doing things that are good for
the city you guys do you guys talking
about batman yeah
yo i hate that guy
but yeah it's like you know how you
subpoena batman's like uh and now you've
got the poor [ __ ] process server
who's got to like trap the crimes and
try to follow batman all over gotham
city
so eventually just hand them a [ __ ]
envelope to show up in court
i i would watch this episode
of uh the dcu legal files
i know right like you could take
superman into court
and compel him to reveal his secret
identity number one he will show up
because he's [ __ ] super there's no
way he's like i answer to no man like of
course he's gonna be like i got a
subpoena so i'm here and he'd be polite
and [ __ ] like that but um
you know as if you're cross-examining
that [ __ ] you could just be like
uh
uh mr mann what can i call you well my
name is cal-el mr l just cal is fine uh
that's too familiar
yeah i guess i'll just go with superman
uh
superman
you do understand that even your name
sets you apart from the rest of us you
know your name by literal definition
means that i am a man but you are
somehow
a super man do you believe you're above
this court
and then you hit him with
then hold on i'm in the middle of my
case your honor
then you hit him with
um
superman do you
like
some of your super compatriots or your
masked compatriots uh maintain a secret
identity
and superman would have to respond like
yes i do for the safety of those that i
love and those around me
i
i have to keep a separate identity from
this one
but it's safe to say uh mr superman that
you don't wear a mask
like say batman or a green lantern uh
this is your real face
do you look like this when you're
in this other persona
um and then he would have to start
[ __ ] spilling details man [ __ ] lex
luthor this is how you get the man of
steel
on details you get them in court for tax
evasion like capone
i mean the other thing you can do
is is
clark kent
gets brought into court
to reveal a source for one of his
stories in the daily planet and that
source is him as superman who saw and
did and witnessed all this stuff
and so
my wife my wife just came in and went
still
i want to watch nope
yeah we've been on for three hours um
we're almost done almost done so much
news
and uh and so clark kent gets brought in
and says you have to reveal your source
or you're then in contempt of court
and clark kent won't reveal himself as
his source and so clark kent then has to
go to jail
because he won't reveal himself and then
a bunch of crime [ __ ] happens because
clark will never break out of jail and
he will never reveal his source because
he's a good journalist
and so you've now got that whatever a
week without a superman because clark
kent is doing the right [ __ ] thing
where can i read this comic book story
mark
no place apparently but in my brain
good [ __ ] story man [ __ ] i i'd watch
that that's cool that's a good i mean
that's a good [ __ ] like uh
five issue series seven issue series
right a week without a superman
and it's fun it's got the hook of like a
world without a superman but a week
without bath man's back and he got
overruled before bam bam what were you
gonna say i don't know but whatever mark
just said
forget doing the comic call the dude
from lego movie let him know
that's how you open up the dcu again
and then the other superheroes are like
that's what that's what kids are
clamoring for to see superman
i showed up for superman and i got this
dude and they're behind a cage
he's clark most of the time and he's
sitting in the house look
that being said i could direct this
superman movie
it's a dude sitting in a jail most of
the time being like boy i wish i was
doing heroic things and everyone coming
in and being like you wouldn't believe
what's happening just outside these
walls
toy man attacked with a giant [ __ ]
tin soldier too bad we can't see it
because clark's in
jail these guards keep coming in telling
them the bad [ __ ] that happens like you
wouldn't [ __ ] believe it man
swear to god the cheapest superman movie
ever made
like smallville because you never see
him in the [ __ ] suit until the very
very end yep and finally clark you know
uh somebody comes in it's like the judge
uh avoided your
your cadet to court mr kent obviously
jimmy olsen
and uh you know he gets out of jail and
he says something pithy winks at the
camera and then [ __ ]
yeah like
lois lane needs to actually come in and
tell the [ __ ] judge
the secret of clark kent so that the
judge can then void the contempt of
court and say you know whatever
like extinction
so she'd literally trust entrust the
judge with the secret
justice is blind
um and she would have to she'd have to
find some some way not blackmail but
you'd have to
you know whatever maybe the judge is
really old i don't know but you have to
have the the way that lois saves the day
and rescues not just metropolis but the
world
is by revealing to one person she hopes
you can trust
the secret
of clark kent
bobby james and chat says i'm sorry but
i remember reading that story i don't
uber coup says they made that movie it
was called hancock is that what hancock
was about
um not really i remember will smith
flying around and doing [ __ ] in hancock
not sitting there yeah like putting
people's asses heads up their own asses
or something like he was he was a drunk
superhero who eventually goes to prison
for for like just violence and he signs
with jason bateman who's a pr guy
and so the pr guy recommends that
hancock go to jail to save his public
image
and that's when he puts people so you
say one more thing about this i'm gonna
ram your head up that guy's ass and then
does it
um
and it eventually gets paroled from jail
and becomes a superhero but i don't
remember being nobody was a journalist
um
who
gets
sentences sentenced for contempt of
court
to spend 45 days in jail
and then uh here's a here's a [ __ ]
pitch viticus in chat says or do a
miracle on 34th street ending where the
post office and thereby the us
government recognizes superman as a
foreign diplomat with diplomatic
immunity or as an endangered species
that's a good [ __ ] idea he could be
an endangered species he's the dodo yeah
like literally like because they say
species it's just never been a humanoid
species before it's always been like a
quadruped or an animal or something like
that but he would be in literally he's
the last of his [ __ ] kind
that's clever
yeah i don't know what what
species list yeah i don't know what that
gets you like what kind of grants get
you know what i'll get you a huge i bet
you get your huge tax write off because
zozlov's about to put them all on the
endangered species list
yeah like clark's like what money do you
think i have i'm a journalist
um that's fun that's a good answer a
good question man j.c you got one uh the
only thing i could think of is like
a movie that opens at sanctum santorum
like post
and it's somebody serving dr strange
papers for medical malpractice that was
that occurred prior or may allegedly
occurred prior to him becoming sorcerer
supreme so you have the sorcerer's
supreme on
trial but he can like roll back time and
change his answer and stuff
ooh that's right he could [ __ ] with the
court case and he's not like superman
he's we've seen
that uh dr strange is morally flexible
right and also has no alter ego so
finding dr stephen strange isn't
difficult because he just keeps calling
himself that
now you know where he lives
that's right you know exactly where to
[ __ ] find him
this is all good [ __ ] well yeah put it
into effect and make it real uh thank
god we're in charge of both the mcu and
the dcu
i'm sorry i forgot i thought it was dan
lin for a second
um and kevin foggy
um
that was fun that was good that's a good
question for a second there i was like i
don't know if i got anything for this
but that yielded
[ __ ] good [ __ ] once we moved into the
dcu everything
yeah
we were stunning by the we we didn't
answer the question we circumvented it
but
it was a response nonetheless yes we
reject the premise of your question and
pose a different one
um
kids
if i know my show correctly
i got to grab the bull by the horns
and uh let you know that that's it we're
done we're out of content
we did it ain't nothing more to say
that's
three hours all week
that's all i could stands cause i can't
stands no more
i believe that was a popeye's thing
um
popeye doyle the star of [ __ ] the
french connection by gene hackman
uh dad jokes and references for those
born in the 70s kids yeah do you like
making 72 cat drummers
here we go
three jobs roy schneider the era of
freaking man
uh kids are you uh
are you uh are you satisfied are you not
entertained
whatever the [ __ ] this free show is over
i mean you ain't got anybody to [ __ ] to
but yourselves man it's about to be done
so if you want to tell us what a waste
of you this time your time this was or
how we suck
the window's closing because
the show is at an end we we shot our
wife we're shooting dust now we got
nothing left
coming at us for a third round but it's
like i'm just gonna be pounding and it's
probably not even gonna get hard it's
gonna hurt
me pushing
just pushing rope at this point you know
it would be helpful though some of that
bluetooth you read about youtube.com
ladies and gentlemen go to bluetooth.com
don't escape that [ __ ] blue chew that
[ __ ] we thank our sponsors the manscaped
folks the bluetooth folks uh we thank
you the audience for hanging out with us
giving us something to [ __ ] otherwise
it'd just be us talking to each other
and [ __ ] which is nice i like talking to
mark yeah it feels like we get more done
if we talk in front of people
it's weird that way but it happens
um don't forget kids clerks three is on
its way clerks three dot movie for
tickets uh don't forget
uh this very weekend coming up uh fan
expo canada i'm gonna be in toronto uh
we're doing jay and sal and bob get old
saturday night we're doing a screening
of clerk on sunday night uh get tickets
to seesmod.com don't forget kids on
tuesday of next week here in los angeles
the city of angels uh right there down
on hollywood boulevard at scum and
villainy cantina we're going to be doing
what probably will be the last live
fatman beyonce for quite some time maybe
until at least december
so you want to come out man uh send me
off as i go off on the convenience tour
uh come see me and mark tickets
available at uh
eventbrite probably yeah nc smart and be
smart they'll be on our social feeds at
some point absolutely come out and hang
out with us man and [ __ ] give you the
inside scoop and [ __ ] still like one of
the best tickets in town in terms of
like if you wanted to see us like you
can't get closer if you wanted to kill
us this is the best opportunity i'll
tell you right you wanted to stop the
convenience tour here's your chance
tuesday night becoming villainy cantina
uh no blasters allowed and no [ __ ]
droids either
uh do you enjoy yourselves kids if you
did
was because uh banff man brought you to
us everyone help uh give it up for banff
man
with his [ __ ] killer young boy hair
haircut look at him no what a young
radical right there the very definition
of punk he ain't giving it up he may be
[ __ ] a middle-aged business owner
with his own home and [ __ ] family and
[ __ ] but he's still dedicated to the
cause kids he answers to no one he's got
a mohawk which is as we all know is the
middle finger to the [ __ ] world give
it up for jc ladies and gentlemen taking
it to the man
um but there ain't no [ __ ] show
without the other guy the dude down
there we're down there dude there yes is
always [ __ ] i'll never get this right
whatever [ __ ] the other guy
the guy that ain't me for christ's sakes
uh marvelous mark bernardin ladies and
gentlemen uh thank you mr smith uh who
you could see
in uh on the daily mail website today
dressed to the nines from the clerk
looking sharp
uh looking very sharp and uh you of
course can also see in clarks three he's
there he's in there clerk's cartoon fans
he plays lando made the cut he made the
cut he's in the movie um there it is my
friends
uh
i think our show is at an end
that
is fat man beyond for this week uh tune
in uh next time
i'm kevin smith
i'm mark bernard tune in next time
that's right same
fat time same
fat channel spodcast.com or
youtube.com
kevin smith
jeff's kiss my friends
[Music]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a ten
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith